so you
[Music]
can perfect
[Music]
what's up guys welcome back to the dope
as usual podcast i am thomas dobasiolo
whatever you want to call me i'm here
with marty o'neal what's up what's up
and as you can see from the thumbnail
and from the banter
from before i said hey man we're going
to start and i'll introduce you well
what about this amen hey guys here's
another episode all right we're back we
brought og back okay og's back okay here
we go great intro you couldn't wait to
get started
he didn't say a word for 30 minutes you
know i said hey i'm going to start well
sorry for everyone driving
um this is my son
he asked me this morning can i dress
like you how can i be like you and as
you could tell
what happened is he pulled up he saw
what i was wearing so i forgot something
he drove back all the way to east l.a
got dressed and then came back dressed
just like me right
mijo always wanted to dress like me
since he's been little since i was about
12 i'm addressing him since the fifth
grade always okay i used to comb his
hair
as you daddy
i used to buy him three flowers i used
to buy him three flowers for his hair
you have three flowers on right now i
don't yes you do i don't if i did it'd
be better than this
three flowers is awesome all right sorry
ready
what's up guys we're back here's the og
episode how you doing
how are you this time i'm doing good all
right let's address something right at
the bat you really really want to dress
like me
boom
check mark
number two
last time you know i go through all the
comments everybody kept saying
you know all you do is cut og off all
you do is talk over each other you're
wrong you've been doing that since
you've been little
so before we start that's normal he does
that before we start guys
if i don't keep talking
he's going to start talking about
something else
it's already happening okay you vouch
for me if i don't keep it on track we're
never going to finish one story so
that's why i go no no get back on track
all the time yeah he's trying to mess
with me at all times so guys not true
it's not true okay here we go
all right here we go how are you how you
doing how you been i'm doing good yeah
for sure first time in the new set yeah
pretty dope i guess 2022 oh [ __ ] damn
it's been
time is different since the podcast
started yeah i know i know it's been a
little more than a year time flies down
[ __ ] yeah it flies how about them
raiders
start this off great yep that's right
how about them raiders man raiders baby
owen 16. i love it i love it okay we'll
take it
i was kidding i was kidding all right
you ready um let's start this off this
time this episode
i asked og what he wants to talk about
guys
i asked him hey you ever done something
like this well what about something like
this so this is a very structured
episode i love this i haven't looked at
the notes don't look at them don't even
look at it because a lot of them are
like are you kidding me
but let's start it off real slow
cool which one are you ready
yeah sure how is life
running one of the biggest dispensaries
in la how is your day today
don't you say it's cool you know what i
mean i mean [ __ ] it's better than ever
man [ __ ] i mean from trapping
for about over
well say 15 16 years
you know out of my own pattern [ __ ] yeah
it's
it's a great feeling you know what i
mean i don't got to go back to the
phone calls and people pulling up to my
pad anymore none of that [ __ ] that's
just over with you know i clearly go to
sleep at night
without worrying about you know
i mean
[ __ ] there would be nights where i'd be
waking up at a i mean literally can't
sleep be awake i got two i'll be up at
two in the morning thinking about damn
what if i get hit damn what am i gonna
do i better put this money away you know
i think i got too much money here
so you know
i would put money
oh wait that was my phone my bad your
phone's off
oh sorry for everyone driving
that's the money count so i was like
wait what's going on i was just saying i
was just talking about my phone going
off and it's going up
[Music]
all right continue
nobody's interrupting your phone calls
nobody's calling you in the middle of a
porn [ __ ]
go i mean nah it's it's a great feeling
you know i mean [ __ ]
i mean i've always dreamed about this i
always knew one day i was going to run
one of the biggest shops i've always
visualized it and now we've seen it so i
mean
[ __ ] it happened
so how do you like it when you go into
work what do you do what's the first
thing you do when you get to work
well when i first get to work on a
monday not a friday first thing i do is
right when i get there i just
whatever whoever [ __ ] up on friday or
whatever happened on friday monday you
best believe that i have it in for it
for them and i'm ready
i'm ready to you know the first thing i
do is [ __ ] somebody up every monday
you know i get there and i'll check my
cameras and right when i get you know
i'm looking to see who's coming in late
because one thing is not acceptable it's
coming late on a monday it's the warden
[ __ ] that yeah yeah yeah
monday's like that's
if i see you don't show up on a monday
after a weekend that you head off
that tells me a lot about you how many
people you think you fired since you've
been there
[ __ ]
over 10 oh for sure over 20
probably all right all right any hostile
ones that you had to drag people the
[ __ ] out
and maybe except for the one we won't
talk about or you know what you're
talking about but yeah i've had a few
you know what i mean
try to get a little you know and
you gotta go you gotta go [ __ ] that
you know so obviously you don't have to
be waiting around there's no stress
because it's illegal money it's a legal
thing yeah for sure
because my other question was how
hold on not even money-wise don't think
it money-wise
what would you rather do
running a shop if there was no jail time
no consequences and the money wasn't a
factor what's more fun
selling packs and going to get packs and
dropping them off
and or sitting in the office and like
running the place
well
you know what i mean selling packs is
always good you know what i mean it's
always a good thing you know what i mean
especially if you're not gonna get
caught up in no [ __ ] i mean [ __ ] i
mean why not you know i mean
but
yeah no it's i prefer
being in my
in my office
you know what i mean i got you with your
computer corporate man
what's the next level above that what's
the goal i mean if you hit the pinnacle
of [ __ ] selling weed at this point
well i mean [ __ ] my next thing is you
know i am you know i'm going to be
starting my own brand soon oh okay i
mean that's that's time okay so cat's
out of the bag on that one yeah that's
gonna be my next one we're talking about
the next move for sure you know what i
mean that's my next move nice yeah you
know i'm hoping you know everything goes
good from there and you know hopefully i
could move on to another next level you
know what i mean
it's like you know like my boss you know
i mean [ __ ] i look up to my boss too you
know i mean i see where he's at so you
know i want to get somewhere too you
know you got the [ __ ] plug if you
want to start making products jesus
christ yeah for sure well we won't say
too much but og and i are starting a
company
a legal company we'll just leave it at
that
we won't even get too into it yet we'll
just say
that
all right how how long are we into this
episode
cause i'm sure i'll smoke this joint so
bad like nine all right we're gonna go
light your joint we good we good brian
all right you ready hey yeah guys it's
[ __ ] working we got monetized not age
restricted and monetized as of the past
couple hours on eric khan right yeah
dude it's fine
so we're good after 10 minutes let's
just chill and then we start it up uh
what are you smoking
uh i'm smoking some uh what is this
emoji some what they call this elephant
elephant growth oh god you got you got
you
got some expensive
i don't know bring it so expensive bring
that up you're telling me it's just
something that's expensive from back in
the day that's expensive yeah we used to
smoke now they just
is there anything that's like
overwhelmingly like in demand right now
as far as like brands or strains or
anything i mean [ __ ] og's always in
demand you know i mean no matter what
you know they can
they can bring all the flavors out but
at the end of the day [ __ ]
it goes all back to og everybody wants
og man i mean because you want to get
straight to it so what percentage of the
people coming in are just buying ogs
[ __ ] i want to say about 75 percent it's
also l.a
you know it's because i mean it it just
almost like you know like taking a pill
you know i mean it's like people want
the [ __ ] that's going to get you too
strong
and what about wax the flour like are
most people coming in and just buying
flour or not uh no you know what it's
rosin you know what i mean you [ __ ] with
raz now yeah i mean people more than
five i mean i mean people that know
what's up and already want what they
want they didn't know what to ask for
they want rosin
nice in reality i mean even the live res
and all that
i mean no disrespect to nobody but you
know to me that's to me what's the
difference i don't smoke no light resin
chemical non-chemical rosin is straight
from the flower straight from the hash
bho uh
butter diamonds it has to go through
chemical products yeah i don't i don't
[ __ ] i don't [ __ ] with them i don't [ __ ]
with no vape pins and all that crap
neither you know is it like any of that
that's a waste of life hold on i thought
live resin i thought live resin was no
uh butane or anything that's incorrect
no it's made with it
it's just it could be salt it could be
all the chemicals purged out of it and
it's great
it's just like yo
that apple was washed with water from a
river well that apple was washed with
like an acetone and then a water wash
after but
it doesn't taste like any different but
just the fact that i know this was in a
clean ass river i'm gonna go with this
so the rosin's more expensive yeah oh
definitely yeah it costs about maybe a
hundred eighty dollars to a hundred
dollars a bit yeah yeah yeah i mean and
uh yeah that's just that all that even
distilling people are still into those
distant vape [ __ ] all that recycled we
talked about it with adam whatever yeah
give us the process you brought the
process down bring your ashtray up here
fool you're gonna they don't sound like
ace of that [ __ ] or do they
distill it the expensive ass uh rosin
[ __ ] well all my jars are only eighths
okay
okay so yeah
so
we eased into this episode all right
let's get [ __ ] into it for everyone's
sitting there going this is kind of
getting slow we just wanted to make sure
youtube's not on our ass you ready yeah
story time starting i [ __ ] wrote down
like eight stories in this are you ready
really what do you mean really
go for it ready
first story i asked you
a little this is how this went down i
asked him
a few hey do you have a story about this
well yeah one time i was like stop
talking just give me the the first word
so i can ask you later that's how this
is going to work
i have a little tagline and hopefully
your ass remembers because only like two
hours ago
are you good
you ready yeah
are you sure
all right drink this whole beer without
putting it to your lips yeah
like that
do it
you're scared you said he brought a
funnel earlier he's scared that was for
his oil and his guests
yeah you ready let's go story time
mexico story with mindy that's all it
says
slash fight story
uh
[ __ ] those are the few fights i got over
there i mean i got a mexican
story with mindy what's that one
um i think maybe that's when uh we were
well tell me this yeah tell the story
maybe
remember
that's when i first hooked up you know
when we were at first hooked up you know
it started
getting her out of
the leave the city's out let's go to you
know
you listening earlier you said let's
just not to say the cities we were in
because of the [ __ ] that happened no
this was when we first we first we first
met we went over there too we started
partying in mexico
yeah but you already said the city do me
a favor bleep the city yeah all right
thank you you're [ __ ] jerk it's ours
you said let's not be too specific on
where we were
the first thing you know i mean well
because this one this was more just like
a it was just more like a um
one of my boys got jumped and you know
we were happy to be there you know i
mean
and you know we [ __ ] you know we took
care of [ __ ] business you know i mean
i know these fools you know [ __ ]
terrible's terrible sorry tell me what
happened
what happened your friend went down
there and you got in a fight with some
people you're telling me no actually all
right so we went down there we went to
go [ __ ] have a [ __ ] have some
beers just this was just like
spontaneously we would literally be like
on a friday night we could be here and
just spontaneously you know what let's
go let's go to mexico let's go [ __ ]
have some beers and whatever let's go
for eight [ __ ]
jump on the car let's go you know what i
mean next thing you know we're [ __ ]
renting this nice hotel we're in this
room and
you know okay what do we do now we're
like in the middle like you know middle
of nowhere kind of you know where do we
go all right let's go here and okay we
got to drive like about an hour away
though
okay let's do it we drive take a drive
out there and uh you know we're all
partying and
so you we
we get to for this first nightclub you
know it's good you know catch a little
buzz you know as the night continues to
go on you get more [ __ ] up more [ __ ]
up so next thing you know
you know i take it upon myself [ __ ] let
me roll a joint so i'm like under the
table and i'm rolling the joint under
the table i'm [ __ ] think i'm all
slick nobody knows what the [ __ ] i'm
doing
[ __ ] no bro before you know it [ __ ]
here comes the [ __ ] lieutenant or a
sergeant wait it comes up too they're
they're they're hard on the wheat out
there oh ball back this is the 90s still
we're talking
okay okay bro [ __ ] the coke's cool back
then i mean [ __ ] it was [ __ ] it was
no joke you know what i mean oh no i
mean coke was still cool but i mean you
just got to know where you're buying it
from
you know i mean if you're going to do
cocoa that you got to buy i'm saying
like that provides it for rounding you
about the coke but they're like oh weed
yeah well basically the way it works is
like if you want to smoke weed you buy
weed from them if you want to do coke
you buy coke from them if not you're not
if not then no you're gonna pay you're
gonna have to you're gonna pay your dues
if you want to do your [ __ ] like a
regular person just come into a bar yeah
doing a line from their own personal sex
it's almost like it's almost like a you
know like a like when you take your own
bottle to you know to a restaurant no
great way to charge you a [ __ ] you
know great way to put the cork fee yes
exactly got you same [ __ ] it's like
saying you didn't buy from us you're
gonna be in our neighborhood give me
some [ __ ] money yeah you're gonna do
it damn that's so good you know so i'm
rolling i'm trying to roll the joint
underneath the desk and you know i'm
pretty good at rolling even back then
i'll still i could do it without looking
at it bro just [ __ ] damn just
breaking it up in one hand and with the
paper on the other hand i could [ __ ]
make it happen you know and i'm trying
to do that and here you go this sergeant
collects me i'm like come here put your
hands out underneath the table
so i mean when he says i like well duh i
mean [ __ ] i dropped most of it
so so he won't have to so he wouldn't
try to tell me like whoa what you had
something so there's no way i was gonna
drop it off yeah but you know i had
maybe like the smallest little crumbs
you could think of
and so i pulled them on like well and he
goes come here and he i still had my
hand he goes don't open your hand he
took me
you know here we go so he took me he
goes open your hand and he takes me in
front of like four of his buddies when i
open my hand i just have like a [ __ ]
little pebble like not even a ball bro
like not even a half a head you know i'm
all like what bro that's all i have i
was just trying to try to put it inside
of cigarettes i could smoke it
his other guys laughed at him like
damn really that's what you brought us
you know what i mean i'm just like sorry
man i mean [ __ ] i go some guy sold it to
me in there you know he's all like
really
who sold it to you i'm like i don't know
and set the restroom somebody's selling
weed all right go back they rushed to
the restroom and you know [ __ ] it i went
back in there and okay there we are
nothing happened we're good wait they
went in the bathroom and and nobody was
in there no they're looking for somebody
that was supposedly who's selling wheat
in here and they went in there and no
one's in there well whatever they [ __ ]
out of to this day i don't know what the
[ __ ] they found they arrested a [ __ ]
innocent person the rest of the
attendant the old man with jolly
ranchers
yeah
i mean who knows
i'm pretty sure they didn't arrest
nobody but you know [ __ ] you know
what happened [ __ ] they went in there
it just made it just what it did it
killed time for me to get to get back
out there of course it was a distraction
right after that i was like cool let's
get the [ __ ] you're leonardo dicaprio in
any adventure movie yeah i mean so we
just [ __ ] we just bounced out of
there and [ __ ] you know we're back on
two other clubs partying and
next thing you know my one of my boys
[ __ ]
you know has this girl and he's carrying
her because she's pretty buzz he's
carrying her
somebody comes up to her and grabs her
well we're about maybe [ __ ] 10 feet away
from him so while he's carrying her
someone grabs her ass yeah
you know somebody grabs her and
next thing you know he's like
he puts it down he's like what the [ __ ]
and i mean this is what he told me what
happened so he's like what the [ __ ] and
you know next thing you know he's he's
getting down with like four fools right
there you know what i mean
so i mean next you know we're we're
behind and we're like [ __ ] somebody's
getting jumped how many people here with
you it's just it's just me and my
compiler that's it just me just two
people oh three total there's just three
of us so my boy with his girl and
there's just two of us gotcha and
there's like maybe
i want to say about four of them
mopping up my boy cause we looked and
we're like what the [ __ ] and all i
remember my boy wearing a
uh was it an indian jersey and we
remember just seeing the
indian the number we're like oh [ __ ]
number oh number one i'm not sure but it
was like number 10 i'm gonna oh damn
fool what the [ __ ] was like that's my
boy so we just started [ __ ] running
like [ __ ] you know i remember i'm
running i'm [ __ ] throwing off my
jacket like [ __ ] superman [ __ ] you
know what i mean like taking up [ __ ] so
as i'm running i'm throwing [ __ ] off of
me and
[ __ ] no it's on you know what i mean
[ __ ]
i mean all four dudes we [ __ ] knocked
them on
cops came they got my compiler they
[ __ ]
they wrestled him yeah no no what it was
was they got his ass they threw his ass
in the cop car
and when they threw the ass in the cop
car they didn't realize that they left
the other side door open and they just
walked out of the inside door open he
comes around and we're like oh he's in
the cop car get him out of there get a
mother and he's behind us he's like hey
let's go
what the [ __ ] you're supposed to be in a
cop car and we're like [ __ ] you not even
[ __ ] it
we bounce the [ __ ] out of there but my
boy that his girl got [ __ ] grabbed he
gets arrested
so there we are [ __ ] figuring out
like how could we get this [ __ ] out
you know i mean like [ __ ] so we're
trying to you know we're walking around
we're asking okay where's the police
station oh police station over here
all right so you know finally we get to
it and you know yeah they [ __ ] how
much you have to pay to get them out
i believe we paid about
[ __ ] back then 90s it was about 200
bucks was it bail or was it you had to
pay him to get him out oh no it was just
a [ __ ] bribe but just yeah just bribe
him real quick 200 bucks and 200 bucks
back in 90s [ __ ]
96 was still a good chunk of little
money you know what i mean probably was
about now maybe about 500 bucks now
but
we'll be [ __ ] waiting for some super
trooper [ __ ] man
we got him out of there [ __ ] it let's
get the [ __ ] out let's go
and yeah we got out of there and
see see what happens when i when i make
you talk more
you said my homie got down and you know
we had to handle it that's what you said
at the beginning
what a better story when you actually
said the story thanks
thanks man loft it up to the room for
him
yeah we [ __ ] hell you dude i'm not a
[ __ ] storyteller but you are i don't
say that but you are though you're a
very good storyteller yeah i mean [ __ ] i
guess once you forget that the cameras
are right here you're fine
that's what nine thousand comments were
this was fine once again we forget the
camera
you gotta start reading some cameras man
read some cameras read some comments
full everybody loves that [ __ ] it's a
good story
that you have not even watched none of
my videos oh you're so garbage crazy one
or two but i do not watch them fully bro
they're great some of our best episodes
are some of the best ones yet
by far i just did a poll about like
everybody's favorite episode on my
instagram and
that was that's in there a bunch of
times well for sure [ __ ] i appreciate it
you know what i mean i do appreciate
[ __ ] you know i mean it's good [ __ ]
for 10
he told me to come back today i'm like
dude i'm nobody bro what do you want me
to like i don't want to be on your show
bro like you know what i mean i'm
feeling like but he's been here three
times i don't want to go i mean i mean i
really don't know how he drugged me out
today like seriously i just asked
i mean yeah you asked but you were like
no bro come on and i'm just like [ __ ] i
think no really i was tripping bro i was
like [ __ ] man i can't chill out ten
years from now it'll still be like that
every time we ask you to come on you'll
be all [ __ ] horrified and then get
here and it's chilling fine yeah we're
just hanging out and [ __ ] yeah no for
sure all right all right that was that
was good that was good
i got two of those i got you one of
these this is a hybrid one
no this is where's the hybrids you
couldn't tell them apart no no they're
too high hold it right here
right here okay everybody see those
you want to act like this man doesn't
know what's what come on my son he
always he always does this to me all the
time i gotta you know
look at him yeah why'd you even listen
to
this
i mean i just wrote them just because i
mean [ __ ] bro honestly you hate that
kind of weird i know you do i brought
that actually this is sure
actually towards the end you know i i'll
be honest with you if you smoke
all day long if you smoke indica like
seriously some og and you smoke all og
since the morning like the way i do
by the time it's one o'clock at night
and you throw some straight sativa in
the mix bro it literally lifts you back
up and it [ __ ] gives you like that
giggling laugh yeah
it's a [ __ ] good feeling towards the
end of the night that's why i brought
that towards the end i'm not ready for
that yet
this is sherbert
uh
sherblotto
no you know what i heard runs
like some [ __ ]
some [ __ ] bro yeah this is
i trust you but hey when he was a young
he was a little kid man i remember i
looked down on him and go one day bro
you're going to roll joints just like me
and look almost the other day
and look at that my son's always
always
this is the tightest joint of all time
no business rolling [ __ ] joints
around og no what it is is og rolls him
so perfect but he rolls them too tight
and they don't smoke so if you notice
when og first smokes the cherry almost
falls off at first he just doesn't want
to believe me look if you do this tweak
it
that's gonna smell perfect now
what tweaking
all right ready
next this is a story time episode
all i see
oh no i wanted to ask this question
story time when's the first fight you
ever got into
that you can remember that was an actual
fight then we'll get into being jumped
that's the first fight
i mean
how old were you
what i was like maybe it was 11 12 10.
i mean what was the story man what
happened well
it wasn't really well i mean look it i
mean like i said i mean i don't know i
probably said this before i mean i went
to private school you know what i mean
and you know and don't say the nurse
wait sorry that's joey diaz that's a joy
idea story when he beats the [ __ ] out of
a nun sorry you just say some raunchy
[ __ ] i just mixed up your story with his
sorry continue so what we would do in
exclusives we would uh we would
so we would create our own gangs you
know i mean because we would you told us
we would read books and you know and one
book we were into in the fourth grade i
remember
is that we were into the outsiders we
read the books outsiders okay you know
so we read this [ __ ] book and we're
like all right the socials and the
mothers yeah you know so i was like all
right cool
next thing you know [ __ ] you know i
divided the class
so the guys that i thought that we're
all [ __ ]
you know the high-end guys [ __ ] you guys
are the socials you know okay made man
and so next thing you know [ __ ] it we're
gonna have a rumble
and we're gonna have a rumble today at
lunch time and it's gonna be behind
behind the [ __ ] whatever the
bungalows and [ __ ]
and next thing you know [ __ ]
i mean lunchtime will be and lunchtime
will be start eating and we already had
our groups there would be like eight
guys over here eight guys or six guys
over here because
because we had the two biggest guys it
was me and my other boy and you know
we're the biggest guys so [ __ ] it we're
[ __ ] so you you're forming a rumble
yes because half the kid didn't want to
do that well maybe i'm gonna say there's
about two two or three kids that [ __ ]
were like no scared and all that but we
put that we put one or two on our side
and they put one and we would we were
like [ __ ] that you're gonna [ __ ] do
this and you know don't be scared it's
just like a agreed upon melee that's
exactly what happened yeah channel 5
news is here it sounds like the [ __ ]
anchorman scene
continues
you know [ __ ]
[ __ ] it here you go [ __ ] lunchtime
finishes everybody's trying to eat their
lunch like a [ __ ] soldier just
[ __ ] fast because i had everybody eat
your lunch fast because we got to get
out there before they you're a [ __ ]
crazy ass little boy how old are you at
this time this was the fourth grade
fourth grade well i mean i mean [ __ ] i
mean it's not i did have i had my
brother and i had my [ __ ] like my
other [ __ ] brother
[ __ ] you know my my like my cousin
brother [ __ ] rest in peace you know
he [ __ ] i would i would look up to
them and this is the stories they would
be talking about uh-huh and you know
they're like 14
yeah they were like [ __ ] maybe about
the time they were maybe 14 15. you're
40. i was about maybe about 10 10 years
old still you know or maybe yeah you
know i'm looking up to what they're
saying what they're doing yeah so i'm
[ __ ] i'm gonna take this [ __ ] to
school kick off yeah you guys want to
have a rumble no we're not gonna have no
rumble where we're just [ __ ]
headlocks this ain't wrestling we're
gonna [ __ ] we're gonna suck each
other up we're gonna [ __ ] we're gonna
hit you know what i mean hey don't be
scared and here and like that here you
go it's the one
so i mean the next thing you know we're
right there [ __ ]
[ __ ] it right when we get out of lunch
next thing you know we're already on our
side one side they're on another side
next thing you know bam i mean i'm
talking
literally like like what you would see
in the movie
ten or seven seven and we just run
straight to each other and just [ __ ]
boom how many kids cry to me bomb each
other um there was always one kid a
parent would always show up the next day
one day like yeah we would always say
like [ __ ] why'd you try like you know i
would get on the next day at lunch and
i'll be like why'd you tire your mom
you know what i mean
black eyes and [ __ ]
organized violence maker sorry not a
bully
you're a gang leader
i'm not gonna say you know i was like
the bully because i wasn't you know i
mean i you know i was bullied actually
when i like i said i don't know i
probably said it before but i was
bullied when i was [ __ ] in elementary
before i went to private school
elementary and i [ __ ] i took care of
my [ __ ] from being a bully i took care
of my [ __ ] you know what i mean i've i
handle these [ __ ]
and that's what got me kind of like they
didn't want me in pr in a public school
so my mom [ __ ]
aog your mic um
when you do this like all right
there you go all right so i'm moving
like this that's cool that's cool
perfect
so so you started a fight
we would start a fight and you know and
we would literally
like clearly for about i want to say a
week straight or a week and a half we
would literally
have a grudge like literally if the
teacher walked out of the classroom and
said i'll be back
we'll literally jump the leader of the
other what the [ __ ] is happening is
the teacher walked out let's get him
right now
you know four or three of us will get up
and we'll [ __ ] bomb on his ass and
you know [ __ ] he's all mexican kids yeah
for sure he's stealing
this we're talking
back then it was called brooklyn now
it's cesar chavez but we're talking
about brooklyn
brooklyn and dozier
dozier brooklyn and mcdonald's you know
what i mean
our lady of social no we don't know what
you mean well not only one person in
this room except for mindy knows where
the [ __ ] you just said man you know we
used to [ __ ] we said no [ __ ] one
person in this room is from here
except for you guys i'm picturing one
eight seven you saw one eight seven
millimeter
that's what i was thinking of when he
did his classes like that the kid that
got his [ __ ] finger chopped off
a picture i'm picturing 187.
hey man hey
i asked you what your first fight was
and you told me how you organized
rumbles what's the first one i mean
actually wait a minute so wait a minute
great story going back to that my bad so
[ __ ] good anyway so we go back to
that so i mean that's what happened i
ended up
so one of the kids like that was you
know we had our little rumbles we had
[ __ ] seven and seven so one of the
kids from the other side all the same
grade i ended up yeah same grade from
our own classroom and they're [ __ ] up
[ __ ]
one of the kids like bad like [ __ ] this
who you know and
like private school by chance this kid
on the next grade level was a seventh
grade or no it was the fifth graders so
he had his cousin
that was a fifth grader and a sixth
grader cousin so they were a lot older
so they actually [ __ ] approached me
you know like wanting to [ __ ] [ __ ] me
up so i'm casually just beating the [ __ ]
oh well yeah for [ __ ] actually that
wasn't your first fight then if you
organized well i know i was because i
mean this who came and they said you
know [ __ ] um
you know i told what it was [ __ ] it is
what it is i mean i don't give a [ __ ]
you know i mean we [ __ ] them up they
said well [ __ ] you he started hitting me
next thing you know we're [ __ ] like
it was like a wrestling match kind of
you know [ __ ] we're both trying to
get on top of each other
next thing you know you [ __ ]
he slams me down on the floor because
he's a lot he's a pretty big he was
bigger than me at the time
so you know he slams me down
so i'm just like [ __ ] he has me down and
while he has me down i'm still like
i remember just still yelling [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you when i get up i'm gonna [ __ ]
you up i don't give a [ __ ]
so i mean he was
i don't know if that intimidated him
that but you know but he still had me
down and you know he did hit me a couple
of times but he let me up you know
so you know
i kind of consider that was my first
fight because he was an older you know
like
it was more like an even fight he gave
me a chance to get up so after we got up
we squared up you know what i mean oh
you guys did find out yeah we we still
squared up even though the the teacher
was like no he's another fight we still
not hell no you know we still went at it
right there and what happened
uh no actually that was still that was a
good fight you know i mean um
i'm not gonna say i won because no no i
was still he was a lot stronger you know
it's not stronger than me but [ __ ] it
you know what i mean i still give it my
best yeah at home give a [ __ ] yeah i
mean oh yeah for sure it was a older
cousin and brother
and back then you know i mean if you had
an older cousin and brother at the next
level and you know at that age so it
forced me being in the fourth grade or
fifth grader you know at back then
it was still intimidating you know like
for sure you know that anymore
and you know i faced them but you know
after that fight you know it's pretty
cool because after that five million me
and dude we all got along after that it
was it was a whole different story even
going
through the next grade level because in
private school you you grow up like you
know [ __ ] everybody in the fourth
grade the next move goes up everybody in
the fifth grade every sixth grade so
it's like you grew up like brothers and
sisters basically you know what i mean
so
it it helped me out that was actually
what you're saying one of my first
little yeah i fought one of the guys i
was one of my first fight
my second fight didn't go too good you
know what he might say fight did you
start it
uh actually no i didn't you know i mean
i got [ __ ] kind of set up what grade
i want to say i was in the eighth grade
no
seventh grade seventh grade what
happened tell me the story because
remember
you have to actually elaborate and
you're doing fine just actually
elaborate that was a great story man how
you set up these [ __ ] kids to get
beat up
you're doing good if i could pat you on
the back i would pet you in the bag man
in the back i bet you on the back man
yo can i give you like 76 pictures of
this thing you know based on the
shirtless look it is what it is
always little stories and story times
had to tell the story tell me how to go
to bed he loves [ __ ] that's where he
got it from like he gets mad when i was
when he was the right to tell my story
he'll be like i don't like the ending
what [ __ ] all right
i'll have to chase andy you know he
didn't like the ending and i don't like
that yeah i didn't like that the good
guy died i'm like well a good guy has to
[ __ ] die sometimes i don't know this
guy wouldn't like it and then i paid the
water bill right and then i paid the
electricity
you're such a fool you know how many
people out there
just caught that think you are actually
my dad now
it's ridiculous dude
you know how many dude i've gotten many
dms is og actually your dad
[ __ ] me like no he's not
don't believe me
he's younger than me how is he my dad
you're not my dad
you're not my dad
all right here we go
hey that was great what's the first time
you ever got jumped so i got no
back to getting beat up when i was like
about in the seventh grade
you know my best friend bro this is
literally one of my own [ __ ] best
best friends
set me up
pulls up
you know seventh eighth grade you know
i'm [ __ ] a little hot-headed i'm
thinking i know it i'm thinking [ __ ]
break dancing and [ __ ] nah breakdancing
was already done with you know you're
already done being mister charlie
[ __ ]
you know [ __ ] high socks and [ __ ]
you know i was high socks and same food
[ __ ] weighing you know [ __ ] farmer
pants and [ __ ] ben davis yeah you don't
even know what's slapping ben davis so i
get set up i get set up with one of my
best friends you know he takes me like
hey what's up let's go [ __ ] i'm gonna
give you a ride
back then i mean in the 90s it was real
popular i mean [ __ ] if one of the homies
had one bike a beach cruiser like it was
like [ __ ] give me a ride get each other
shove them on the [ __ ] on the
handlebars or you [ __ ] jump them in
the back you know what i mean
i'll [ __ ] let's just just chest to
chest right let's go take a little ride
so here we go it jump on his handlebars
well actually he jumps on my handlebars
we go [ __ ] take a little ride around
the [ __ ] neighborhood and uh
there was a girl that you know [ __ ]
yeah i used to like and this other guy
used to like so he just pulls up he's oh
hey stop at [ __ ] homies pad right
here and i'm like [ __ ] this dude you
know i just two days ago i just [ __ ]
got into it with him and he didn't
[ __ ] want and you know what i mean
he's oh i'll pull up i'm like all right
we pull up
this [ __ ]
he pulls up to his food and he walks up
to his window he's like what's up fool
hey um
i got [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] password right here you
know he calls about my nickname but i'm
gonna try to say my nickname it tells me
i got password right here it's weasel
tits
sorry
he's all [ __ ] he wants to get down
with you
and i'm thinking what the [ __ ] i'm like
really i'm gonna [ __ ] it you know
well [ __ ] you know little did you know
that this fool had his brothers and you
know his brothers from a neighborhood
and [ __ ] no
they all [ __ ] came out before homeboy
came out to fight me they all came out
and surrounded me in one big circle
and they seen that i was [ __ ] like
[ __ ] you know i'm gonna take off my
shirt you know what i mean like [ __ ] it
i'm gonna get down with this fool
nah man i just know that one of the
homeboys one of their one of the
homeboys you know he tells me you know
what i'm still a youngster you know what
i mean [ __ ] i'm still like i think i'm
like 12 years old yeah i'm about 13
years old you know what i mean
and these fools tell me like
you're going to get down and when i'm
like i'm ready to get down you know what
i mean he's all right you can smoke this
bro you can't get your ass [ __ ] i got
one right here
[Music]
what are you smoking right there the
good one no [ __ ] it's just good
you're tripping like see what i mean
what i gotta go through it tastes like
bubbles been happening since we first
started smoking the last episode
remember you're talking about the edges
bought that pound and he was like got
him yeah so you guys did don't hold it
against me you heard last time got him
that was different that was when the
pandemic first started that's true that
was four months ago
yeah i mean it was four months ago four
months ago
that was about a year ago
you know you were on here in december
yeah and it was like maybe four months
before december it was like 21 episodes
ago yeah yeah bro where are you at
it doesn't change it
yeah somebody do the math on that sorry
sorry this fool's over here
that's all you always complaining here
take one of mine
these are fire you'll see the difference
you know what i'm gonna [ __ ] try your
[ __ ] [ __ ] right now
and if you don't like it i got it from
your shop
you better like that
you must
i mean it's good i don't know i mean
maybe i don't think it's ready these
little too wet you'll taste it
you'll see
yeah man you're gonna go all right fool
i get it sure well anyways they tell me
these fools like all these fools pass
they tell me you get they tell me
instead yo you ready to get done i'm
like i'm ready and they're like no
you're not ready you're gonna get your
ass kicked and i'm on no i'm not he goes
yes you are
and i'm like what the [ __ ]
and i turn around they're all [ __ ]
looking at me like
are they older
oh bro they were all older they were
like [ __ ] 18 17 16 you know they're
some loser [ __ ] beating up a little boy
hey straight up bro go beat up a little
straight up straight up on some [ __ ]
[ __ ] i look at it now and i'm like
well you guys were all [ __ ] [ __ ]
homie you guys ganged up on a [ __ ] 13
year old homie that's crazy you know so
anyway so
i looked i'm like [ __ ] you know i guess
damn man what the [ __ ] well [ __ ] what do
you mean i'm gonna get my ass guitar you
can get your ass kicked and i'm like
[ __ ] so this fool comes out the house
like [ __ ] you know like like he's
already
and i'm like [ __ ]
i go damn i go i'm [ __ ] i know i was
[ __ ] [ __ ] next you know bam
he just [ __ ] ran up on me and [ __ ]
i tried to give you no one but now bro
it was i'm just standing there and he
comes and blasts you and then they just
it was it was more like it was like the
dude got me for a sense that he tried to
talk to me to distract me and as soon as
i turn around to say like what's up that
fool came right at me boom hit me next
thing you know i'm on the floor he's
[ __ ] kicking me
and i'm seeing flashes on my face
because he's kicking me in my face so
i'm like boom boom i [ __ ] this
[ __ ] he got to me you know what
i mean you want to be a soccer player so
i get to get up and i'm like [ __ ] it you
know i literally tell [ __ ] you got me
fool [ __ ] it is what it is yeah
with the one kids kicking you only yeah
they all didn't jump you well the thing
was that if i would have fought back
gotcha they would have [ __ ] like if
it would have been the opposite there's
no way it would have happened i mean we
all know that [ __ ] goes i mean yeah it's
their [ __ ] you're gonna stand there
and let you just beat this kid
you know i do the same thing for my
people i mean [ __ ] them
but i get it you know what i mean so
[ __ ] i got my [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
could have been worse i guess they kind
of all stopped you out i mean and not
only that but my best friend was there
watching uh that's my next question what
was he well no we're getting a bike
after that and we're going back to the
house
and i'm [ __ ] up now he's giving me a
ride because i'm [ __ ] up i can't even
[ __ ] pedal i'm just like [ __ ]
holding on and i'm like [ __ ] and he's
telling me
oh you got [ __ ] up food
you didn't do [ __ ] i'm like
[ __ ] oh you know [ __ ] you
know [ __ ] this fool you know i'm over
here you know [ __ ] shorty there's
more [ __ ] there this fool and this
fool they were there like really fool
like they told me [ __ ] i'm getting my
ass kicked or otherwise they're gonna
[ __ ] me up and he's all like i didn't
hear that fool you're tripping i'm like
[ __ ] hey so [ __ ] you know i
mean i go home
you know i tell my mom that i [ __ ]
that i hit the curve and i [ __ ] hit
the pole and that's why i look like the
[ __ ] elephant man you know what
i mean
but my face was [ __ ] [ __ ] up she
believed in me
but she no [ __ ] no she didn't believe it
like [ __ ] no
like she believed it you should be like
she was a court
because she was probably [ __ ] nervous
herself and getting me [ __ ] ice and
[ __ ] to put on my face and everything
but the next day like after she started
putting [ __ ] together she's like charlie
this wasn't a [ __ ] accent and i'm
like yes it was
so [ __ ] it i don't know there's a cortez
print next day [ __ ] there's a cortez
print in your forehead pasquale she said
hey put your phone on [ __ ] silence
what's wrong with you i thought it was
the second time
only you and dr drew huh
he's an active doctor
just click it go like that click
and it'll be on silence
sorry for everyone driving
he does have patience
[Laughter]
so he [ __ ] you up your mom said hey
charlie that wasn't an accident right as
you said yeah well anyways [ __ ] next
day [ __ ] i see my boy
i know i you know i come outside i'm all
[ __ ] up
you know and i see one of my boys that
just moved into the neighborhood and
this just happened to be some [ __ ]
straight out you know
bicycle that just came from mexico
you know and he was like
he was like
like i want to say a gang member from
mexico but this will have some like
weird ass tattoos like [ __ ] like
apocalypse
no back then i mean they would make they
would make tattoos out of charcoal like
you know they would charcoal and they
would [ __ ]
poke themselves [ __ ] and then he
would tell me so that's some chippy
tattoos but this one was like some crazy
food you know i mean he was a fool i
didn't realize he was a full tail he
seen what was wrong with what happened
to you and i go [ __ ] because you know
it's [ __ ] you know he [ __ ] me
up and he
he tripped out like that how old was he
look like
this i mean look food check this out
this food was maybe he was it was your
same size you said it was a [ __ ]
problem he was my same size but i want
to say this fool was you know because
this was from mexico they don't even
sometimes i'm not not to [ __ ] talk
[ __ ] but you know they come from from a
ranch and [ __ ] and i'll be honest with
you sometimes they don't even know their
[ __ ] age bro they'll guess that or
they'll just say hey i'm [ __ ] 20. and
little do you know you do the math or
you really find it like what [ __ ] are
you you're [ __ ] 17 stupid you're not
20. you know what i mean because i have
cousins you know from mexico and you
know because they never went to school
so i feel bad when you're 17 stupid
you know my cousin's from mexico too you
know and they try to bust some [ __ ] on
me tell me they're 20 you're not [ __ ]
20 you're 17. and they don't even know
[ __ ] one year they were born you know
yeah you know [ __ ] uncle
[ __ ] probably [ __ ] up and told me
you're born 84 you're more than 79
okay
you know
anyways um
[Music]
[ __ ] this dude [ __ ] you straight
[ __ ] told me you know what [ __ ] that
get on the bike let's go [ __ ] find
this guy like the dude yeah was he older
than you though
yeah he was older than me he he said he
he claimed that he was like
17 but i was like [ __ ] no this guy has
to be a little bit older you know but
really he was about maybe i was about
maybe 19. where did he move at on your
block so i so i know he moved up the
street further like [ __ ] like where
pastor pastor guys passed my house going
towards the pastor guy
yeah exactly okay gotcha i got you so i
mean [ __ ]
so he was just coming by and was like
hey man nice to meet you all [ __ ] them
up no he no no no not nice to meet you i
just really i met homeboy maybe about a
week ago oh you did that you already met
him before yeah i just had oh it was
weird because he had just moved into the
blog
and he just [ __ ] did some crazy
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] fool you know i mean
just the way we met it was just crazy he
tried doing a trick in front of us
[ __ ] flipped over and [ __ ]
[ __ ] a [ __ ] bro [ __ ]
literally ain't [ __ ] [ __ ] bro
like cartoon [ __ ] [ __ ] you know what
i mean flipped over [ __ ] yeah
but he's gangster or [ __ ] happy exactly
we're like hey come here and you start
talking to him
so you know so the next thing you know a
week later i get drunk you're [ __ ] up
you know he comes up to me and tells me
like what happened and i'm like well
they this food jumped me and he's like
oh and i go well [ __ ] remember home on
the other side that we just seen a
couple days ago different neighborhood
why no no just to cut another next block
over gotcha yeah same neighborhood but
next block over and you know we're still
kids and [ __ ] so
nobody goes oh yeah you know what
happened how'd you get beat up by him i
thought you could [ __ ] that fool i'm
like no man like oh he had his brother
he had his [ __ ] cousin and they had
all their [ __ ] homeboys and their
[ __ ]
he's on the bike there's no way that i'm
gonna be able to right each other guys
on a bike
which way the guy from mexico he's oh
yeah he's on his bike you know he says
get on he tells me you know what get on
let's go
he had some pegs you know [ __ ] jump
on him and i'm [ __ ] running let's go
you know what i mean and i'm [ __ ]
looking like an elephant man you look at
the [ __ ] [ __ ] the mask you know my eye i
couldn't even my eyes looked like oh you
know [ __ ] ever literally everything
was closed it looked like sloth from the
goonies exactly [ __ ] yeah so i'm [ __ ]
we're going back and i'm [ __ ] just by
coincidence man we [ __ ] find this
dude like literally like 10 minutes
later wait the guy was he alone he was
with some other skater dude because he
was skater so he was with some other
skater dude the kid was a skater that
brought his gangster older brothers to
[ __ ] you up well yeah because we pulled
let's not forget my best friend set me
up and took me to his house and [ __ ] it
you know what i mean
his brothers and you know his homeboys
were all happy to be there so when they
said hey this was here to get down with
me he told his cousin so they all came
out surrounded me of course they're
going to be here
and told me you're going to [ __ ] get
your ass kicked or we're gonna [ __ ]
kick your ass yeah cause like [ __ ] yeah
sure was funny all right they get an ass
kicking by this dude you know he's he's
my age but instead of getting [ __ ]
refereeing a little kid fight that's fun
to them all right so [ __ ] it i took i
took it [ __ ] it next [ __ ] day like i
said i'm i'm with my boy we're cruising
and he's all like we're just like [ __ ]
there they are look and he's like
[ __ ] yeah this was all i know is that i
jumped off his pegs this who got his
bike and just let it go the bike kept
rolling [ __ ]
and this fool [ __ ]
not knowing spanish but just in the week
that he hung around with us wait not
knowing spanish well not knowing english
okay you know okay not knowing english
this [ __ ] literally picked up
the word [ __ ] and stupid from us
and stupid [ __ ] so this will [ __ ]
just threw his bike and the first words
that came out was like
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] this and he didn't
make sense but he just heard that [ __ ] a
lot of times
and he writes [ __ ] me you're [ __ ]
right he ran up to the dude that [ __ ]
me up
he [ __ ] bombed on him [ __ ]
literally [ __ ] bit
[ __ ]
he bit him bit half of his tear
get him
and i'm right there watching and and
he's right there with his friend and i'm
telling his home his friend like what's
up you know and his friend's like nah i
don't want that and i'm wait wait you
know sorry hold on the grom he's biting
the kid's ear yeah
so my boy got some in a headlock and
next thing you know my friend just
[ __ ] bites his ear damn
bites half of his ear off
the top of it
and this dude when he's biting them this
was [ __ ] screaming ah
next thing you know [ __ ] i'm right
there and i'm just like [ __ ] yeah what's
up [ __ ] i'm trying to i'm trying to get
a [ __ ] like let me kick his face
but if i kick his face my boy face is
right next to him so i'm like [ __ ] i'm
gonna kick probably my friend and i just
like yeah so i'm still like kind of like
[ __ ] let him do what he got to do
because literally [ __ ] bro
i'm gonna say my vision was like
like a [ __ ] 30 bro this side was so
close were you scared i didn't really
see like we're just like damn they might
[ __ ] pack me out again
you know what i was scared we're going
but you know one way i was saying i'm
gonna catch this dude alone he don't
he's not with his brothers you know this
is this is he just supposed to she met
him at the skate park he caught him at
the skatepark no i caught him in you
know one of the [ __ ] parkways you
know what i mean what do you mean like
an alley or something uh no in a parkway
like [ __ ] just in the middle of
[ __ ] one of the little islands that
are in the middle of the neighborhood ah
no [ __ ] how close do you live to you huh
how close did you live to you [ __ ]
one block to the next block yeah i mean
they jumped you like that and you lived
there well i mean the thing is that you
know and already
everybody's close you know what i mean
but [ __ ] i know but to live a block
away
that's pretty close
to have these older brothers surround
the kid that lives next door basically
that's crazy as [ __ ] well the thing was
that you know [ __ ]
he still didn't have a clue who my
family was you know so he was
he he had no clue
after of course after his his cousin you
know his little brother's ear got bitten
off
i'm pretty sure after he did his
homework and he found out who my
brothers were and who my you know my
older brother was like i mean so he
[ __ ] were astonished when he bit the
kid's ear off or did you know he was
that crazy no [ __ ] no bro
i was [ __ ] i was loving it bro
i was loving every bit of it because
right after
he left him on the floor
[ __ ] bleeding this fools [ __ ]
start screaming my name and he starts
grabbing like the little trees i'm gonna
kill you
and i'm laughing at him like [ __ ] you
i get all my boys back on his back on
you know let's get out of here
we drove off
well you know [ __ ] next thing you know
[ __ ]
i got like [ __ ] all his cousins and
homeboys looking for me
little do they know they don't know that
it's me related to someone yeah they're
just like they're looking for me so as
they're walking around the block looking
for me wearing in um this you know at
this guy's house is this this one guy
that you know [ __ ] bit this food here
we're at his path children you know so
his backyard he has like a little back
roof so we're in the roof and there's
lemon trees and [ __ ]
next thing you know i'm like [ __ ] it
look at they're walking down the street
[ __ ] we start i start grabbing
[ __ ] lemons and i start [ __ ]
aiming them towards them
next thing you know brother [ __ ]
walking up and down my street i hit one
of them oh [ __ ]
walking up and down my street so
therefore they run into [ __ ] my
cousin and next you know they know like
nah [ __ ] no that's my little cousin you
don't [ __ ] you know you don't [ __ ] with
them and
they're what they're looking for you
yeah they're looking for me and then
they finally figure out who i was
related to by walking around looking for
you yeah guys
you know they happen to pass by you know
our house and next thing you know it's
like
what's going on
and it was done after that oh it was
[ __ ] weight done after that man for
sure i mean [ __ ] there was no way
they were gonna [ __ ] you know i mean
damn did you stay friends with that
crazy ass kid from mexico for a long
time he moved back uh actually you know
what i'm pretty sure you're friends with
this dude
and uh he was for how long
until he moved back i wanted to feel bad
you know what i had to this day i still
don't know what happened to this dude
but you know
i want to say
he stood there for about
two years at the most
yep you know and
that was it then he was on to his next
venture did you expect another
like did you i don't know i didn't
expect him to do that that's you know
what actually that was like that
that right there is what kind of gave me
that like
like oh [ __ ] you know [ __ ] this dude was
[ __ ] down for a while he took care of
me like you know here i'm all [ __ ] up
you know i could take the chance of
fighting but dude
any hit on my face right now i'm [ __ ]
up bro it wouldn't even been good yeah i
mean so i mean for this dude took care
of [ __ ] you know to me at that age it
taught me he's [ __ ] it taught me a
lot
like you know what hey this fool was
down for me and you know i mean so he's
solid you know what i mean
yeah that's awesome and to me you know i
mean [ __ ] i've always i've always been
you know i mean did the kid attach his
ear back on or not so much you know i
don't even know what happened to that
dude you know he ended up
you know being one of them dudes that
you know [ __ ] say they're from the
neighborhood but they move out to
another city
and [ __ ] like [ __ ] out of here you know
what i mean
you're from your neighborhood you stay
in it that's nice if you want to play
that [ __ ] oh i was there you know yeah
you don't you don't try to play that
[ __ ] and you move to another neighbor
you know
you're [ __ ] from where you stay
you're [ __ ] you want to play that
[ __ ] you know what i mean
yeah
hey what's up guys thank you so much for
watching this episode so far oh gee
won't stop talking during this ad read
but yes thank you so much for watching
this episode so far just wanted to take
a moment to talk about one of our
longtime sponsors this is on it let's
hop right into it guys www.onit.com
onnit.com forward slash yola that's 10
off of everything on the website except
for the weights if you're a long time
fan you've seen on it on our channel
many times but if you haven't real quick
this is human optimization on it is a
brand from head to toe anything you
could possibly need for your body for
you to get better on it offers if you're
like me and you can't sleep melatonin
spray if you don't get enough vitamin d
vitamin d spray and their staple product
guys that's alpha brain you've seen it
on many podcasts before and on ours and
in marty's life for 10 years and in mind
for the past
eight months so now alpha brain comes in
shots just like little drinks this big
it comes in peach and tropical so if
you're watching this and you have any
interest whatsoever go ahead and use our
code that's codeola that gets you 10 off
of anything on the site but the weights
just go to onit.com that's
onnit.com forward slash yola that's our
code for the discount as always guys
thank you so much for supporting the
brands that support us back to the
episode
so
you might tyson the kid
then they found out who your [ __ ]
family was and said hey we're just going
to leave it alone and you never saw the
kid again and then you moved away yeah
dude moved out to like some other city
i'm saying
yeah yeah i get it was he older and i
would still no actually no i wouldn't
say major go to school with him and [ __ ]
uh no i didn't go no he no i went to
private school bro oh that's right
that's right that's right
do you think your life would be
different if you didn't go to private
school oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah he was running those [ __ ] kids i
probably have more [ __ ] fights
probably or something than before you
know i mean yeah for sure yeah
okay okay
so
that was a good uh that was a good one
i'm gonna get into one little thing
and i'm gonna call this trivia with og
oh all right give me a second
can't wait for this [ __ ] give me a
little second all right
so
[ __ ] you're wearing glasses now so
what's up sir i mean wearing glasses
just like his dad i'll tell you
look it up [ __ ] yeah yeah
these are my interview glasses these are
we just want to ask political questions
not political questions but i got some
trivia for you some of it's dumb
some of it's just stupid yeah that's the
categories
all right and i i just i i did this
because i think
i want to know what the [ __ ] you're i
told marty i want to know what his i
want to see your face when your brain
goes
all right what are we going to say
all right ready
here's the first question it's just a
random one
when was america founded
when did america become america
this guy no i just want to know what do
you think well i mean i don't i guess
america became america when [ __ ]
christopher christopher columbus [ __ ]
that's what he said that's what he said
i mean i mean oh no founded not found i
mean when did become america like become
the united states of america what year
do you think it was fun
i just want to know i don't [ __ ] know
maybe [ __ ]
yeah i think you're going to be close 19
14 some [ __ ] 1914 no 14 no i want to say
[ __ ]
yeah about 1400s right i don't know i
just wanted to i know i know what the
the number is because it's a dumbass
fact that some people know really yeah
but i just wanted to know what you were
gonna say what about christopher
columbus
i mean i don't know i'll do that he
didn't discover [ __ ] he thought he did
yeah he just
went and said visited someone else's
life yeah he came over here and rolled
up and all of a sudden [ __ ] he said
he discovered something
bulk [ __ ] we were already here you know
it's like if i found your joint went
damn i discovered marijuana yeah exactly
like yeah i already rolled that [ __ ] and
smoked it for sure all right i just
wanted to know where your brain was
going to go with that question
thank you for sure you ready for my next
question
yeah that was good i like that one do we
do we want to put the actual answer out
there i think it's like 1776 correct
correct it's 200 years before you were
born young boy
really yeah you're 200 off oh [ __ ] and
when you when it's when it's stuff like
that you got to do that you know what
maybe i'm thinking maybe i'm thinking
about the 1400s no they both said 14
something because christopher columbus
discovered america it's not propaganda i
don't know really was it fourteen
ocean blue yeah
was it 1492. there you go he knows he's
[ __ ] tall he was educated i mean i
know i was sports i mean look when i
would go you know what i did in private
school was i would pay attention but you
know i mean you started rumbles
[ __ ] we know what you did in
private school
these are making me feel different i pay
attention
oh you know i mean i listen and [ __ ] you
know i'm not a person that likes to
speak up too much what i do is i listen
a lot and i like to [ __ ] absorb a lot
you know what i mean
you wait just wait i don't like to say
my opinion around a lot of people i like
to just listen i mean a lot of people
will say [ __ ] [ __ ] don't say
nothing rosie
i got to tell him the same story 66
times for him to go
oh yeah yeah here's the answer
44 times and absorb oh [ __ ]
how many times more they go watch watch
me tell og this thing and he's gonna go
what are you talking about right after
it's i've done it live for you too
justin i've done it for you many times
are you ready
yeah that was the question that should
be dizzy [ __ ] those glasses
all right america
what's up with america are you ready
second question
who do you
think would win in a fight
between a bear and a gorilla hold on
and why do you think that
go
really
well i would think the [ __ ] bear
would win
why
why
tell me why i got to know what your
brain's thinking
[Laughter]
give me honestly you know what i'm
thinking right now go if you had to
choreograph it and go hey step by step
draw this draw a bear to gorilla fight
why do you think the bear what's the
scene that the bear wins why you know
the bears [ __ ] claws bro
that's what it is okay you don't think
gorilla could be like yo get behind him
and choke his ass out
might be a little stronger but [ __ ] one
claw to his [ __ ] chest
he's gonna rip that [ __ ] right
open okay
that i i wanted to know thank you guy
you guys were all laughing because i
knew he's gonna he's gonna pau you even
said
he's gonna go like this
but he didn't because he had a joy in
his hands if he didn't he would have
all right marty who do you think's gonna
win between the bear and gorilla i'm
saying gorilla i'm going gorilla
gorilla's to bite flesh and rip things
off and a bear will too
but a gorilla
is a [ __ ]
beast it's it's like it's up in the
trees and it's [ __ ] there's two of
those bears
i mean the bear's first strike is
[ __ ] going to be to claw your ass
that's true and that [ __ ] con that
first strike it's like it's like you
know it's like a [ __ ] that say
you know i don't know how to [ __ ]
fight but you got to watch out for that
one [ __ ] punch i throw cause well you
better hope that one [ __ ] punch it's
gonna [ __ ] knock you out no no i i i
totally agree with you but i feel like
the greater thought about that could be
i don't i don't know what happened i
don't watch usc i mean i can see a
gorilla but i can see a gorilla trying
to stomp the [ __ ] bear out and it's
not gonna work that's a bar fight i
don't know if this is going to stop him
well i mean every time i you know i mean
not every time but i remember [ __ ]
back in the days if i see a
[ __ ] gorilla [ __ ] be
stomping the floor or something
girls oh
[Laughter]
[ __ ] private school i don't know why
did you guys really yeah well i've been
in the zoo forever right okay something
in the 90s
[ __ ] early 99 actually this was still
[ __ ] late 80s
so yeah pre-jurassic park the zoo was
like some [ __ ] big [ __ ] because it
wasn't [ __ ] to do there's no video games
what else you do to [ __ ] distract
kids the zoo and the [ __ ] the
science museum or something they just
take all kids are scared straight just
walk them through a [ __ ] penitentiary
oh see
you see
that you couldn't do that in certain
parts everybody to see their parents
okay you ready
i like that answer
thank you for explaining why
i'm going gorilla gorilla bear you ready
for my next question
ready
there it is
you sure
oh gee
what is your plan
how would you fix the homeless situation
in los angeles california
[ __ ] man [ __ ]
create homes for these [ __ ]
that's what i would do
[ __ ]
i'm just saying a lot of these fools
don't [ __ ] want to be in homes man
they [ __ ] want to be about home [ __ ]
you know what i mean [ __ ] i'm so glad i
asked this guy you try to help somebody
else i'm not going to even want your
help nowadays you give it home
i try to give homeless money anything
tell me [ __ ] out of here
you didn't ask me for money i'm like
[ __ ]
all right so you know
i don't know it's hilarious i knew he
was gonna go into what he hates about it
but i said what's the solution give him
houses
that's the obvious how do you fix the
homelessness you [ __ ] you know just
build them houses
yeah
that was the most direct but it was a
true answer i just thought you were
going to go into something else first
did you think that's what was the thing
was the director it was the most direct
hey man how do you stop all these
[ __ ] floods
dry the water up that's what you just
did to me make sure there's no water
yeah i mean [ __ ] how do you stop gun
violence and kill everyone
you could probably fill a whole empty
city with la's homeless people right
like
a big city you can fill buffalo with
la's homeless people ah there's a lot
you work downtown it is [ __ ] wild
because he has the craziest camera
system
you can see down the alleys far blocks
away that's i never thought about that
you just sit there oh man
the guy the old bomb that was in the
wheelchair and he hit up the tag
what the [ __ ]
he was loose dirty tanks he found this
breakout on the floor
he was one of the homeless guys that
kicks themselves in the wheelchair
like bro you're just sitting at this
point yeah and he just put
and we're just watching him you can zoom
in like your lens
when they're on their system pretty
awesome yeah sorry
so that's how you're gonna fix the
homeless side well i mean honestly you
know uh [ __ ] all right no
that's perfect try to create homes for
these people i mean [ __ ] but sometimes
nowadays they don't even wanna be in
homes they're they're more comfortable
out there where they're at i mean [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] up thing i mean [ __ ] but
it's true how much worse is it now than
when you were growing up
oh [ __ ] are you kidding me bro i mean
it's so [ __ ] up i'm gonna tell you
right now
one day i was going to work in the
morning and i literally seen
a family bro a [ __ ] family and
literally the the mom literally combing
the kid's hair bro a little kid
kid looked clean still you know but [ __ ]
literally living on the [ __ ] streets
[ __ ] horrible that's horrible i've
seen this [ __ ] feeling i mean not
only that but she made me so grateful
that morning whatever i was [ __ ] mad
at like
i was not mad at ever again
and you know every time and to this day
bro i still use that bro you know what i
mean if i think if i think i'm having a
[ __ ] bad day i think back to that
[ __ ] day and [ __ ] my day straight
i'm [ __ ] grateful i mean i think
about that you're driving up here all
the people onto the freeway he's in
orange county there's no homelessness
yeah did you know that
i'm pretty sure there might be some
homelessness i just don't see them of
course there is homelessness what i'm
saying no you get to there's another
level
there's not a problem they're discreet
about it they're hidden now it's crazy
going through his city dude every
street's clean
the trees and the fog that day
we see homeless people like in l.a it
was so bomb but there's like it's insane
not to see homeless people like that in
every street even in the richest
neighborhoods in l.a yeah beverly hills
is [ __ ] up did you smoke my joint you
smoked that other one no this is your
joint i'm gonna finish it fire oh this
is your journey right here i'm gonna try
this [ __ ] right now
you just said that's mine no this is
this is your drink that you didn't like
ah okay okay i thought it was good it's
good i don't like it really it's got the
soapy bubble taste a little
you want to taste that like right here
i'm back your tongue
no that's not it i know what taste
you're talking about you don't talk
about yeah that's nice it's almost like
a dryer sheet in the hot room this is
not it
yeah i know what you're talking about
all right cool as long as you know what
i'm saying so i can see why you're
saying it but okay as long as you don't
think i'm an [ __ ] that's exactly you
know exactly what i'm saying
you're a jerk
um perfect
thank you hit this
it is you'll be fine
you'll be fine all right that got
through my uh trivia
ready
oh my god it literally says how would
you fix the homeless problem here in l.a
on my notes [ __ ] yeah so uh getting on
to this next piece of uh story time
next door i asked you about i'm just
gonna say the beginning and then you
just take it away
illegal gambling in my garage
no from the start
like how it progressed i just played
something
for one day you know one you know so
okay so you know i get my pad this is
[ __ ] we're talking [ __ ] almost what in
the 1900s no this was adam
this is a ball maybe
16 years ago maybe 15. let's just say
20.
[ __ ] it whatever
[ __ ] hypothetically so you know i get
my pad you know [ __ ] allegedly
money's [ __ ]
it's good and [ __ ]
you know we're [ __ ] back then you
know it's [ __ ] down and everybody
[ __ ] sure knows [ __ ] uh
it was a laminar swap meet [ __ ]
centerpiece brings out swami okay and it
was like [ __ ] you know the [ __ ]
friday night show people hang out night
time they had friday nights yeah it was
popping if you're hanging out
back then and [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
yeah it was popping up more now it's
it's the same you know swap means aren't
yeah
you know just
back then you know [ __ ] i was still
you know we're young you know i just had
my my my first daughter you know [ __ ] so
we're [ __ ] go to swami and i see this
[ __ ] pool table i'm like not pool
table [ __ ] okay a [ __ ] poker table
well you know he just had pool tables
poker tables he had everything wait up
guys selling them yeah you know and i'm
just like damn [ __ ] that's [ __ ] a
legit [ __ ] poker table
well [ __ ] [ __ ] next thing you know i'm
just trying to do how much and he's
telling me like [ __ ] i want like [ __ ]
400 and do it you know 500 bucks and i'm
just like
how about [ __ ] 350s nine
yeah for sure oh wait long time ago 350
that's like 800 bucks today yeah oh yeah
okay you know 350 400 bucks you know it
it wasn't stable still you know it was a
little pretty pricey so you know i'm
like [ __ ] that working well trying to
well i'm dealing so [ __ ] next thing
you know he's like [ __ ] give me 300 i
take it home 300 yeah you got it down to
three
okay so i get this table set up in my
[ __ ] garage and set it up
they say you know people are coming to
me because i so we had a shop there too
so we were like oh [ __ ] you got a table
yeah man you want to shoot down friday
you know you might have
friday whatever you want you know if you
want to [ __ ] play
[ __ ] you want to play the house you
know i got you you play blackjack poker
whatever you want and they're like [ __ ]
they're like all right cool are you just
making it up just to try to get people
to know no no i mean because i was going
i was already starting to go to the
casino a lot you know i mean we're
starting to go oh this is that hey how
many [ __ ] phase of your life yeah so
i'm already [ __ ] you know i'm like
[ __ ] i know how to play 21 you know
[ __ ] blackjack and [ __ ] poker and
all [ __ ] so i'm like [ __ ] it i'm telling
everybody [ __ ] you want to play [ __ ]
21 poker [ __ ] it this friday here you
know saturday
next thing you know [ __ ]
people are showing up to buy weed and
have a game
like [ __ ] you here let me get announced
and you know what i want to take a game
you almost spent 100. oh so i'm like all
right [ __ ] it i'll give them [ __ ]
change
next ain't no [ __ ] bad there i am
[ __ ] it
you know yeah i'll get him okay i got me
[ __ ] the most you know the house
always wins there we go so you were so
you're basically in your own
neighborhood going yeah come on in i'm
coming in oh yeah bro and who was
dealing and playing for you you're the
one doing it yeah so yeah they're
playing me i'm the house you know
they're playing me so you're playing
everybody you sell we too yeah i mean
[ __ ] there they want to take their
chances and don't get me wrong i mean
[ __ ] out of like [ __ ] uh
12 people that rolled up to play i want
to say three people [ __ ] literally
won but with other people losing you
know you're fine i won yeah it didn't
matter so [ __ ] yeah
three people will leave winning
and when dude will come on the next time
say i lost dude will come that one be
like [ __ ] no i won so dude would be like
[ __ ]
them back you know there's hope you know
i mean so they would come back and be
like [ __ ] i'm gonna have 200 bucks
and yeah [ __ ]
them you're selling them weed you're
right you're robbing them for the
[ __ ] money of the casino basically
well no they wanted to play that was
their choice well i'm saying like you're
always winning you're you're cleaning
them out oh yeah but most of the time
you're winning 80 of the time my phone
right winning yeah yeah about eight of
the time you're winning which is great
so
how long are you doing this until it
becomes a night like a night where
people are coming over just to play well
after that it just becomes like oh [ __ ]
you have poker nights and they're like
[ __ ] i'm like daily
saturday nights saturday after everybody
gets paid for sure and friday nights it
went to well friday nights turned a
little more crazier because that's when
everybody gets that's when you get
everybody that could get away from the
girl like oh i got the check we're gonna
drink with the guys back then and boom
next you know they're at my house you
know what i mean
yeah so you know i mean [ __ ] [ __ ] it
would get right bro i mean
so so i'll tell you this
go
and it was wild bro [ __ ] [ __ ] poker
nights were [ __ ] so loud
i'll tell you this they're all right
look at that [ __ ] you i mean
so why not poker night so so we would
have poker nights on fridays
in your crush and i would provide the
beer because i had one of my boys one of
my one of my boys
casino out here he worked at budweiser
so this this [ __ ] [ __ ] literally
[ __ ] traded you for being back then
was five bucks a case of tall cans 24
ounces a case like a face a case but 20
like maybe 12 i don't know it was 12
that's all [ __ ] tall cans for five
dollars yeah that's a lot you charge
five bucks a piece so back then they'll
be like [ __ ] bro bring me 300 400
i would have my [ __ ] fridge filled
all with tall cans but like budweiser
[ __ ] stella's before before stylists
even [ __ ] became a green bottle yeah
right had [ __ ] styles filled up
and uh i would literally [ __ ] free
beer on the house
so
we would gamble you know we'd be
gambling and there was moments where
like you're the only dealer one guy no
yeah yeah for sure
always
uh no actually we would change we would
change dealers like all right you want
it we're going to let you deal it oh so
you're probably dealing so nobody would
[ __ ] get like say oh you're [ __ ]
you're the one
you're probably [ __ ] around with the
cards they're not gotcha you won and
this forgets the cards now you want you
get the cards
so we're doing that but there will still
be always those little naggers that will
try to get all [ __ ]
you know loud and [ __ ] you you know how
did you get the wild card and this and
we'll be like what the [ __ ] and i would
hear these you know a lot of these fools
you know they were just customers of
mines but i would see how they would get
when they would get drunk
they'd get pretty loud where you know
honestly they would be kind of talking
like you know some words you say you
just don't say you know what i mean and
i'd be like all right you know cool
so one day
one day i just said you know what i'm
tired of all this screaming and bitching
[ __ ]
[ __ ] it i went inside [ __ ] i got
[ __ ] six guns
six of my guns and i gave everybody a
[ __ ] gun i'm like here you have a gun
you have a gun everybody has a [ __ ]
gun so now i don't want to hear no
[ __ ] bitching and yelling
shoot yourself in the hud
[Laughter]
kill yourself if you're gonna complain
you know what i mean
it was like you're not gonna complain i
don't wanna hear
you trying to call this fool a certain
name because we're not gonna tolerate it
you a gun and you got a gun so you gave
a bunch of trucks
drunk mad guys
losing their money guns yes terrible
encourage them to shoot each other awful
decision
but it worked it worked it worked i know
that that's somehow combined
everybody knew better like oh [ __ ] he
has a gun people really will blast me
next to me so now it's like you know and
i'm [ __ ] as christ [ __ ] it you know i
mean that that was the best thing to do
because i wasn't gonna tolerate the
[ __ ]
yelling [ __ ] you know what i mean
yeah i get it so how long did you do
that for it until it got too much for
you you know what after i got too wild i
want to say took about
maybe almost a year and a half oh
a while maybe a year and a half maybe a
year where just like [ __ ] it i had to
stop it after it just got too [ __ ]
long and everybody's at your [ __ ]
house all the time dude
[ __ ] got way out of hand you know what i
mean but was it about you liking the
hangout and [ __ ] or it was just about
making money basically it was more
making money but you know it would turn
out like you know i started getting more
people coming in and it just started
getting a little more like random people
yeah no not round yeah actually yeah
random because like i brought this guy
next you know my store was just getting
more bigger and bigger like i was just
getting more people more people
like [ __ ] i'm talking this is [ __ ]
ridiculous bro yeah you only got so many
guns to hand out to [ __ ]
oh yeah well when we had games yet no i
mean i actually did that for a couple of
nights just to [ __ ] you know just to
shut out the certain crowd that i had at
the time
you know i was just [ __ ] they would
always wolf too much and like [ __ ] this
look here here you go you want a wolf
now there you go you know what i mean
that's how it is playing basketball in
the hood
people a gun oh you want to [ __ ] you
want to travel
you want to travel
get out of here marty they're not
handing out guns
for fouls
by the way it was a terrible idea but it
worked
it worked it worked and yeah it was not
awful
she could have been that she could have
went could have been sick
but at the time i'm gonna tell you
you know my mentality was still like
you know i didn't give a [ __ ] you know i
get it
ended the rest of you ever seen
reservoir dogs they all shoot each other
and [ __ ]
that's how i imagine that
so illegal gambling in your garage
amazing let's go back south of the
border again ready next story packs from
mexico
stop saying cities stop [ __ ] up
there's so much ash all over you it's
awesome
i mean you're covered it's awesome
[ __ ] i i mean [ __ ] mexico it just says
pax from mexico
[ __ ] that's all it says i don't know
[ __ ] uh tell me so
[ __ ]
i want to say maybe
so i don't know my last one i mean i
told you about how you're [ __ ] nice
to [ __ ]
get packs but in high school you used to
sell over 500 yeah 500 packs
so as we started getting a little bigger
how that [ __ ] ended
was um
i ended up getting set up
you know i mean we [ __ ] in mexico
yeah oh [ __ ] i went got some packs
and um
you know back then [ __ ] i started off
with [ __ ] i was i'm talking i'm still in
high school bro i'm not even [ __ ] i'm
not even 21 i'm not even 18 you know i'm
still [ __ ] i want to say maybe 16 to
17 or you know i mean
not even you know so [ __ ] um here's
your asmr i'm [ __ ] i'm over here
buying [ __ ] packs
[ __ ] i start off with maybe
[ __ ]
two i started off actually with one and
a half
you know i'm [ __ ] let me buy a pound
and a half
and then for a pound and a half the bug
i would go back because we're going
frequently all the time
so
[ __ ] the next one [ __ ] it two pounds
three pounds four pounds
five pounds next you know six pounds ten
pounds and
so
it went all the way up to where we had
20 pounds and at 20 pounds these [ __ ]
set me up you know and i'm not getting
it from like no [ __ ] like no connect
where it's all like what you see in the
movies like oh fuzz guy god's pounds no
i'm getting it we're literally in a
[ __ ] poor
[ __ ] neighborhood where literally
it's just
i'm probably getting the bottom of the
barrel yeah straight up you know what i
mean
so at 20 pounds these [ __ ] set
me up why [ __ ] cops
wait the people get you're getting it
from or the people you went with set you
up
no no who i was getting it from oh you
know
what a couple of times it was good good
good next thing you know [ __ ] they
tell me you know today
if you take you know because i only
wanted i think i only wanted 12 i think
and i was like you know i'm only going
12 pounds you know what i mean like [ __ ]
i don't want that many you know how much
you're trying to give you matter of fact
i i'm i'm still i don't even know what
[ __ ] 12 pounds still was i was like
[ __ ] i'm getting a lot of [ __ ] weed
you know what i mean you're just hoping
and assuming they gave you 12. yeah so
no no i mean i'm just like well i want
to buy you know [ __ ] 12 pounds like
all right and they're like well if you
give us the rest of your money we're
gonna give you all this is 20 pounds i'm
like [ __ ] something damn that's a lot of
trips um i'm like
you know i'm like [ __ ] let me get it
so [ __ ] we get it leave
and then now i get set up by the cops
because i get pulled over now you drive
out with the 20 pounds yeah and i'm not
even driving
my cousin one of my cousins driving so i
get pulled over we get pulled over
next thing you know they're just like we
know you got packs where they're at and
they knew everything so they [ __ ]
next you know [ __ ] they wanted money
and they thought we still they assumed
we still had money that's what everybody
thought
so they're like
we're gonna go see the judge right now
and
you better [ __ ] give us this much i
think they wanted like another [ __ ] back
thing i think they want to get a
thousand dollars
and i'm still [ __ ] i'm still a kid
bro like and i'm like [ __ ] i don't have
a thousand dollars so [ __ ] let's go
see the [ __ ] judging you know i had a
thousand dollars you know what i mean
i'm like it is what it is let's go see
the judge if anything [ __ ] i got my
family that'll [ __ ] take care of me
and get me out of this mess right yeah
i'm like [ __ ] it
and they didn't even want to do that
they were like no wow we're going to
take away [ __ ] some of this weed they
just let you keep some yeah they took
[ __ ] like once they took maybe a few
pounds maybe five they just want to
bribe they took some pounds for me and
he [ __ ] so i ended up with the usual
they just steals my money you know they
[ __ ] got me
so was he an informant what was help
with the plug why would oh there's one
of the weed backs like [ __ ] [ __ ] in
mexico i mean [ __ ] that's the way it
works right yeah [ __ ] i went to a
[ __ ] one day i just went to go have
some drinks and leaving the place [ __ ]
they pulled me over
and
this dude pulls out instead of pulling
out a [ __ ] uh blower like what you're
supposed to blow do you you know [ __ ]
blower
[ __ ] pulls out a [ __ ] magazine
for what any [ __ ] folks he's smelling
and he tells me blowing it and i i'm all
in the microwave he's gonna blow he's
not blowing it you know i'm like what
the [ __ ]
he's uh yeah so
he folds the magazine you know up and
they're blowing it
and his nose is on the other end he
tells me oh air drum you should have
spit a little and i'm just like what the
[ __ ] i'm like i'm like you should have
inhaled you know so i'm like that would
have been tight you know i was tripping
i was like what the [ __ ] are you kidding
me that's like breathalyzers in mexico
you've been drinking you guys you've
been drinking
and [ __ ] yeah straight up put your
lips on me
and you're drunk straight up [ __ ] you
know you just [ __ ] [ __ ] bribed me
though wow
you've been drinking how much you know
i'm not gonna charge you he's i'm not
gonna charge you a lot but what you got
right now everything's a bribe there
yeah basically okay so you know
basically what i do before i go to
mexico i [ __ ] stop and i [ __ ] stop
stop
just leave it at that no need to talk
about that you still go to mexico to
stop it
you're gonna tell me later and go [ __ ]
man oh can you take that out
do me a favor
let's uh bleep
it'd be funnier if you just
today on the dope's usual podcast we're
gonna be smoking pcp
wanna do a bunch of masculine
oh we should do mescaline and get so
melty that our face is on the table and
you should frame it so where me and og
are having a conversation with both our
[ __ ] faces just flat on the table
[ __ ] up that's awesome that's views
that's a
ketamine episode
where i'm just laid out of the table
with one headphone on and there's like
it's really talking
zoomed in and marty just making sure i'm
not dead
that sounds amazing
and we're back we're not gonna say
things that jeopardize safety financial
and or prison time
go can you put the notes back up sorry
yeah oh you took seven bathroom breaks
right now
[ __ ] guys
he pooped a lot
a little [ __ ]
mario
are you ready my pinky ring
all right so uh illegal gambling in your
garage you terrible decisions but it was
great packs in mexico you got set up
they took your [ __ ] ready cop story that
was it right uh yeah actually after that
um
so i mean i did i i got caught up in
some [ __ ] over there you know what i
mean and um
[ __ ] you didn't we didn't we talked
about this earlier is this gonna be bad
yeah we should we should just leave it
out it's [ __ ] good you know what
we're saying though all right so let's
just go back start all over there
because it's just started again so they
just [ __ ] i'm gonna leave it you're
gonna i'm gonna leave it off i'm gonna
leave it
nope
are you ready
it just says taking hondas at night
taking on
you burned a hole in my seat
so you know i [ __ ] at the time i
think i had a
it was a 94 90
no it was a 92 honda civic i believe and
you live in the apartment right you just
got with mindy yeah no actually i was
yeah we haven't lived we moved to
apartments and you know [ __ ]
storyboards i had my
you know i would do my deliveries and
[ __ ] you know and people would get off
work i'll go drop off pounds to them you
know three pounds here two pounds one
pound you know
and uh
you know my car i thought it was all i
thought it was burned out you know i
mean because i was like always mobbing
in it yeah you know so i'm like [ __ ] my
car's burnt you know what i mean it
looks [ __ ]
noticeable so you know i had one of my
friends that worked at the at the
honda's [ __ ]
at the hondas at the honda civic or i
mean at the honda dealer
and uh so i would have to just give them
the vin number and he'll give me the key
for it
so who what hondas are you using so i
was using my neighbors honda from
downstairs
just that just them well i used their
hunter because they had a brand new
[ __ ] honda like
they literally bought it like
right were they old
no they were they were old you know they
were no no no no they were no they were
they were about
they were a little older than me so i'm
saying you know i mean oh
why haven't they noticed that the
you were like what 20 at the time uh
yeah i was about maybe 20 21. and the
kid upstairs got the vin yeah got a key
made from his friend at honda which is
[ __ ] up
yeah it was fun it was [ __ ] up
yeah
you know for sure i'll leave the gas
full
that's cool i would wonder like every
time i go to sleep and wake up i'm
pretty sure they got a whole [ __ ]
tank they probably not it wasn't full
but it was maybe about a little more
than half ways already and then they
were like i got
they had about a quarter they had about
a quarter tank you know what i mean so
he gave him a quarter tank he used their
card themselves [ __ ] i made him i made
them believe in prayers you know i mean
what does that mean i mean [ __ ] they
woke up the next morning there's gaston
to take it like
stealing into gas
[Laughter]
jesus
that's what you just did to me
they woke up and made them pray
for your gutter ass like reverse uber
right i'm going to steal your [ __ ] but
don't worry
i would use your card in the middle at
night like maybe about [ __ ] from 10
o'clock to 12 i would jump in their car
and i would take off in it
early hours i would still might be awake
oh no 10 o'clock oh no hell no i mean
[ __ ] did you know them did you ever talk
to them in person oh yeah i knew who
they were oh so you knew what kind of
people no they i didn't know yeah i knew
what type of people they were they were
just the straight working people and
they got you
you know i mean they were like
programming you know money
yeah well not too many miles because i
would just straight go maybe from where
i was i want to say about i would put
maybe about 14 miles that's not bad it
wasn't bad you know every night though
um maybe
three times a week four times wow that's
[ __ ] insane
nobody ever knew nothing the whole time
i would take off for about from 10 to
like maybe i'll be back like about maybe
ten or one in the morning two in the
morning i'll do all my drop offs drop
everybody off and you know [ __ ] with
everybody when i get there
and they would they would trip out like
oh i like your car i'm like yeah yeah
thanks man i just got it you know
[ __ ] it was my neighbor's car you
know
[ __ ] you're not freaking out at all
because they wouldn't you i hadn't i had
the older honda civic well i pulled up
in a new honda civic so then you're like
[ __ ] you know you're pulling up in the
knee on the ceiling so you're getting
gas
taking the car back parking it and
locking it yeah for sure
have you ever washed it
what i mean what did you ever wash it
watch the car [ __ ] no there's one enough
out of all the time
actually you know what i noticed that
that you know i i noticed that i'm
[ __ ] no they always had a clean car it
was always [ __ ] clean because they
were ready for it was ready for you they
were they knew like oh somebody else is
going to be in here it'd be polite to
clean or maybe they just knew that it
was going to be for me
maybe there's so wait i mean it's an
apartment if you lived above them
or they lived up above you i lived i
lived above them so they're on the
ground floor they can hear your car even
closer no no i mean so there's a carport
so like you know i would walk down just
jump on the car i know but is it right
underneath the apartments or right next
to it no it's actually you know it's a
good 25 feet away oh okay so i'm
imagining like right [ __ ] oh no no no
it's like about 25 feet away
get on their car boom i'll go around a
parking spot like their parking spot
yeah did anybody ever was anybody ever
parked there you got back
well you know what one time i almost did
get caught i believe because um
i pulled up and after i pulled up and i
parked their car i'll tell you this i
parked their car back
and i remember going back up to my
apartment i remember them coming out
looking at their car
like they came out quick and they it was
like if magic happened they seen their
car there again you know what i mean so
they were like like oh my car's back
well your car's back and no it wasn't
harm nothing did they see you walking
back no they didn't
they didn't see me so how did you know
they went outside because okay so the
way the parking structure was like i
could have came around
through the back or to the front and
that day when i parked it i parked it
and i walked straight just like around
the whole i went the opposite way
because i had a feeling because when i
pulled up i seen their door open with
the lights on so i said [ __ ] i think
they're [ __ ] they're up why is the
door open that's never open at this time
so when i parked that i didn't see
nobody it had just been at the moment
where
dude maybe i'd walk back to his house
and was just dying like say [ __ ] it
they're they must have the cops on the
phone saying they stole their car but
when i pulled up and backed it in right
when i got off i walked opposite way
and [ __ ] just
i
i didn't do it after that because i knew
they they found they knew they knew yeah
but they just they were like still
tripping like who did him
he was a
because there was nothing wrong with the
doors or anything because i had the key
the master key for that car
you know what i mean
all i had to do was give him the vin
number and i'd get the master key it
opens everything starts the car so there
was no damage done to the car so i think
they were still kind of tripping out
they they thought that they were [ __ ]
tripping maybe did we go out and miss
the car maybe they did you know what i
mean
maybe wow i had a thing i made i wrote
it out because i thought it'd be funny
to break into people's cars and just
clean the [ __ ] out of it and like put
new stuff and then just leave like yo
someone smashed my window i mean
whenever i got into it one thing i would
do is i wouldn't even smoke in their car
because you know how nice try to keep it
clean
well my thing was to keep it clean
because i didn't know women are children
i wanted to keep i wanted this thing to
keep continuing going good i didn't want
it i wanted to keep stealing their car
so i was polite enough not to smoke
i mean think about it
if you get in the car next morning your
smile is like we you're like something's
up but if you get in your car next
morning you're like [ __ ] my gas tank
went up damn [ __ ]
you know you drove these people crazy
for months do you inadvertently
terrorize
that's awesome
[ __ ] hilarious actually that's
amazing love it i used to just take the
cars and go do drugs with my friend joe
but you're out there [ __ ] doing
productive [ __ ] i like that yeah i was
just delivering certain cities like [ __ ]
and that new little car [ __ ] got me
everywhere
you know what i mean i was next to cops
at moments where like they were trying
to look at me and i just wouldn't even
look at them you know i'll turn this way
like i'm looking for something i'm
looking i'm trying to read a map or read
a book trying to i mean not a book but
like a map like trying to get directions
and i'm looking it's always going to
look good right by me you look up like
you're looking forward to be like [ __ ]
it you know what i mean [ __ ] that's how
you get away from stuff yeah you look up
trying to look innocent or you go like
this
yeah i'd never make it don't make
contact with the cops at all at all
that's how you do it martial where he
looks like a cop and he's a [ __ ]
explorer
god damn right i know
well not anymore but
you're really not gonna get pulled over
though they're like look at this
businessman
in this long car that's what they're
gonna
okay this perfect guy
hey man it's okay don't worry i'll i'll
work i'll talk you through it if you
want to hold my head you want my glasses
like in big daddy
you don't want to be invisible julian
always hold your hand everybody used to
hold your hand we first jumped in the
lake remember when i took you to the
lake
remember my first time we ever dressed
to like remember i had on that red suede
jacket and you're like man i would love
a red suede jacket remember when you
[ __ ] first rolled your bike can you
[ __ ] hit that tree
okay he balanced himself and he went
straight into the trailer she wanted to
say something real
the way he said [ __ ] [ __ ] man
remember that time
when you threw up in the lawn or
something
i hate you a lot the first time i ever
rode a bike actually i just came back
from mexico i saw this kid that was beat
up and he was beat up real bad and then
we went and [ __ ] up this guy bit his
ear
really yeah it was crazy
he didn't even listen to me remember i
said i was hungry i had to say story 60
times because i just told him his own
story back and he didn't realize that i
told him his own story back yet
did you realize that you didn't yet no i
didn't so i knew it brody who wrote this
joint
did you put something in here no you
just hit it with a why does it have some
kind of little oil stain i don't know is
there oil in here
no
somebody put oil in here justin rolled
it
what'd you throw in there huh that's
beard oil that's a beard oil that's that
pittsburgh saliva
weasel that's that weasel
okay here we go here we go here we go on
to my next story
i just wrote it on there
and for the next part of story time
it just says acid story
that's it it just says acid
you tell me you remember when we called
about an hour before the [ __ ] and i went
over the notes
what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] bro [ __ ] i thought we talked about
that
you're saying it like it's a [ __ ]
jeopardy
acid story
for 100. do you want to get how i got
started to selling asset maybe i don't
know you guys oh sure you just said
write down that story oh [ __ ]
how i got started selling acid was
[ __ ] um
i started bullshitting people you know i
mean i [ __ ] um i would get the
[ __ ] um
so i started off you know my dad smoked
marbles you know marble reds lights
threads
so i would [ __ ] you know i would
[ __ ] i would jack his boxes
and what i would do is what do you
explain it though [ __ ] don't
know what that is the marble box you got
the two little horses and you got the
little crown
on it well i don't know if they still do
it now but back in the days it used to
be like that right
so i used to always cut that little edge
where that little crown was
and the little [ __ ] horse and i would
just make a little [ __ ] square like
the size of an acetab
you know and i [ __ ] you know one day
took about [ __ ] eight of them
just [ __ ] around like [ __ ] it you
know
let me see what happens yeah i'm gonna
take these scares take them to school
i sold them to a few few people
that never did acid before
you know
and these people are [ __ ] coming out
coming up to me after and saying [ __ ] oh
gee i'm tripping or not oh gee my bad
you know back then you know i was
[ __ ] a pasquado [ __ ] [ __ ] what's
going on [ __ ] tripping okay i'm like
really this we're like in the 11th grade
10th grade so enough they're older to
know better though 10th grade no no
actually no
you know let's not forget i was going to
whittier and you know [ __ ] whittier
was more like
more like you know you got people from
the hills from friendly hills and
[ __ ] you know
rich rich you know what i mean rich
people you know you're supposed to them
so many yeah exactly don't get me wrong
i wasn't selling to anybody or any of
the [ __ ] low classes what they were
doing i was saying you know like i said
when i was in high school i used to get
along with everybody you know i mean
[ __ ] did you go to private school in
high school too no oh just middle school
just all the way up to the eighth grade
eighth grade
that's when you turned into oh so you
got kicked out yeah i got kicked out
that's right that's right okay so you
sold and they're acting like they were
tripping so [ __ ] man these girls were
literally acting like they were tripping
and these little these girls literally
the next day were telling me like [ __ ]
we want more could you bring more buzz
club please bring more and i'm just like
[ __ ] are you just supposed to be smart
all right
some more i'm gonna bring some more so
there i am [ __ ] go back i'm trying to
see if my dad has some extra boxes you
know
maybe about two boxes and [ __ ] left one
box about the cartons
no no yeah you know and i'm trying to
get him for the boxes you know my boss
made me who knows they spoke like a box
two boxes a day back then whatever so
i'll [ __ ] [ __ ] you you know collect
them
and i already knew where to come i'll
tell them oh yeah these are the crown
the golden crowns and everybody [ __ ]
believe you're such an [ __ ] you've
been lying to [ __ ] your whole
life i mean my my thing was like mamma
mia my thing was jerk my thing was
[ __ ] you know let me see all right
you know i'm gonna get these little
[ __ ] rich kids
so actually you know i'm getting them
so now i'm like [ __ ] this i gotta give
me some real [ __ ] acid you're gonna
so now i start asking him i need some
real ass and i started looking around so
sure enough i ran into one of you know
some one of my other boys and he tells
me i got you
next thing you know we're [ __ ] i'm
getting micro thoughts
and
[ __ ]
it's [ __ ] pretty local after that
everybody in the whole [ __ ] school
knows i'm [ __ ] selling the micro dots
and
how much you sell each one for and i
want to say back then it was uh
25 bucks yeah 20 bucks ahead
[ __ ] that's like 55 dollars well i mean
[ __ ] one michael dodge [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] you were late back then
when i was buying an extra scene
you know three hours
four hours you know you're [ __ ] you
know wow that's cool so were you taking
them too trying them oh yeah that's when
i started trying them and
you know
my actually my
my second time was a [ __ ] drop
because we were dropping um they were
dropping off that acid drops on the
[ __ ] sugar the liquid ones yeah
so i [ __ ] ended up taking it on my
[ __ ] left left hand you put it on
your eye yeah i took a drop in my eye
and god damn bro
to this day [ __ ]
i don't know if i'm back yet oh my god
oh no what happened i'm just saying [ __ ]
bro it was some [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] it was just some wild [ __ ] man
just going to
do just gone bro i mean i want to say
two days maybe a day and a half
a day and a half i was [ __ ]
i wasn't i wasn't right did it hit
different going through the eyeball
huh did it
and it hit maybe about
i want to say seconds bro
what did you feel i want to describe
acid to me i mean [ __ ] all i know is
that [ __ ] everything just melted
literally
[ __ ] melted on me like
anything i see it just melting down
melting down like even your floor was
like literally like [ __ ] i'm it was
like if i was walking it was like if i
was in mud
but not the mud just there's mud
everywhere there's no food everything
just stuck to you
i mean everything was stuck to me i mean
i seen squares on the floor next you
know the squares were literally on me
you know like in a creepy horrible way
oh bro it was [ __ ] it was something
different bro where'd you take it after
this day i still were you at school yeah
school i took it
third second period saying how you took
it at 9 30 in the morning second period
i took it and
i want to say um
by
by lunchtime i was gone had someone
[ __ ] take me home
and i just couldn't i remember the vice
principal came up to me and um
i was like i was standing sideways
and she i thought i was standing
straight
and when she walked up to me i was still
sideways she was standing straight and
she's telling me stand straight i'm like
we are straight oh my god
and that's what she told me you know
what she's uh i need you to go home
who's gonna take you home could you call
your mom to pick you up and i'm just
like wait she knew you were [ __ ] up
and said i'm not gonna get you in
trouble just leave yeah wow oh yeah oh
yeah bro i'm telling you this was like
dude you ran [ __ ] straight
i mean i'm not gonna try to say like you
know but i'm not trying to say i ran
school no i didn't but for some reason
just in my path i always ran into
[ __ ]
people of my [ __ ] that's why i always
believe that you know we've always lived
the past life and you know you get them
again so you know and
the way my universe creates my
my life is i ran into the same people
that i
worked with before
so i believe that you know the way how i
run into like these vice principles that
are just as cool as [ __ ] like you know
they they know what's up they know what
time it is and
they they [ __ ] they just told me you
know what go home like you know just
like something
something you know a [ __ ]
a mother is looking out and it just
knows what's up what time it is been
through the [ __ ] too tells you you know
[ __ ] i know what's up go home
you know what i mean yeah
so you were so [ __ ] up that was
basically it you know she told me you
know you got someone to take you home i
got someone taking me out so go home now
and you know
you were tripping at school a lot
he's sideways i was [ __ ] i mean [ __ ]
bro i want to say um acid was one of my
switches one of my shit's in high school
i mean i [ __ ] loved that so you were
selling it you took it you went home you
were [ __ ] up for two days yeah i want
to say i was [ __ ] up for about a day
and a half
and then after that i mean you gotta
wait you can't just pop acid right after
right after
yeah i mean back then i believe it was
like you gotta wait you know a couple
days before you [ __ ] pop some more
you won't feel it so you can get that
effect you know i mean back to that
regular effect again
i mean at least that's what it was back
then that's what we used to always say
now you gotta wait 72 hours or 73 hours
before you [ __ ] take the next one did
you still sell it after that
yeah after you know i got a good plug
where i was getting
back then we had uh they were called
felix the cat
and it was a felix the cat sheet
and you know all squares and
[ __ ] rip it up
[ __ ] you know
was the eyeball thing only like a once
in a while thing or was that like normal
what was that putting it in through the
eyeball
bro
dude it was just the dude that i ran
into with some [ __ ] some
i mean
put this way sorry
the way i look at it now is like if you
were into somebody back then and now i
think about it the dude that sold acid
back then
he didn't sell acid
because he just saw acid he sold acid
because
he got somebody in in his one of his
older generations that sold acid and
nose and you know and [ __ ] it just
travels to a generation of families you
know if you're a family that's always
[ __ ] with shrooms
you know this room is that's just very
standard
you know what i mean so that's how it
was you know i mean
this dude [ __ ] acid
already was in his generation family
damn so you know so i knew dude knew
what he was talking about and you know i
was getting the real [ __ ]
so i mean you know i would sell acid but
you know i'm not gonna lie i didn't sell
acid i just say [ __ ] i was you know
sold a lot of it but i would get sheets
here and there and i would [ __ ] i
would have to [ __ ] get rid of them
and just with that that's what got me
started people knowing who i was and
next thing you know that's when i said
you know what
i think i need to bring some weed over
here too i got weed but i wasn't just
bringing in as much
this is before mexico
no that's when yeah right before mexico
and that's when i started figuring out
you know what i need to [ __ ] bring
some [ __ ] weed over here because
everybody [ __ ] wants weed and
everybody doesn't want acid because a
lot of these kids are scared yeah
they're scared of [ __ ] asses
no one acid
everybody wants weed so it's like well
[ __ ] that i'll make i can make more
money off weed instead of [ __ ] acid
yeah so that's for sure you know
let me [ __ ] start with anything so
that's what got me to bring started
getting weed and
you know i i started off with you know
the small plugs right there around
people that i knew by an ounce two
ounces
so just one day i went to to [ __ ]
mexico tj loops is back to the story
from before
and the story from the last time yeah
and that's when i [ __ ] just said you
know what [ __ ] i could find some butt
over here some weed over here and
it started off over there and that's
when i [ __ ] started just
let me bring two pounds they bring i
started off with i'll be honest with you
i think you started off with maybe a
[ __ ] i don't know half a pound it was a
half pound i think you said or pounding
it started off with something small you
know something like that wasn't nothing
you know wasn't much
but just with that if me breaking down
all that
oh man it [ __ ] killed him
i was like [ __ ] went back and
brought more back more money back and
they're just like oh [ __ ]
just started building up where like
it just got to somebody else where he
got good enough where he got i believe a
thousand or some [ __ ] got somebody else
and they just said
[ __ ] him let's get this guy and they set
me up
and they text me
about [ __ ] yeah about [ __ ] five
pounds who knows they text me and yeah
did that stop
your flow oh you know actually when it
was happening is i ended up having one
of my other best friends rest in peace
you know he died [ __ ] a while back
way back
and um
him and his brothers were involved in
other [ __ ]
and he goes you know what i got what you
want you know you don't need to be doing
this
it's like going to mexico serious i'm
like [ __ ]
you saying don't need to be going to
mexico because no he goes you don't have
to go over there because i got you
you know but he still gave me a little
mission like you got to just do this and
you got to meet this guy here you got to
pick up this car and i'm like jesus [ __ ]
it i'll do that and
got into that next thing you know
i'm in a tire shop
[ __ ] you know
opening up tires and [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] pounds that were like [ __ ]
tired looking and everything gas tanks
you know what i mean and [ __ ] it it's
crazy about the guys i got more wheat
than you can [ __ ] imagine bro and i'm
still
[ __ ] with like 17.
i got a [ __ ] no more trips [ __ ] no
bomb
saves you [ __ ] eight hours no more
trips yeah the wii smile like gasoline
and [ __ ] you know but it was like
shit's gas [ __ ] it
we got it [ __ ] yeah no one cared about
them no especially because i [ __ ]
smoked that [ __ ] people smoked this that
smoke [ __ ] that [ __ ] you know back
then i mean i'm this
you know [ __ ] was sprayed or whatever
[ __ ]
that was
[ __ ] i couldn't [ __ ] help it
yeah well thank you that was that was
the acid story that looped back into the
weed story yeah i like this
are you ready i have another one for you
we're going back to back to back-to-back
and i think this is my last one
you ready
you called me back and told me to throw
this in there
and i'm gonna lead into it a different
way
so one time
i was at your house
we're hanging out and we're constantly
[ __ ] with each other because of
always
and i was talking to you i'm like hey
what's wrong with you you want [ __ ]
drugs so what's wrong with your stupid
ass speak [ __ ] and i go are you
on [ __ ] drugs or something me talking
[ __ ]
hey tell me are you a [ __ ] hero are
you on [ __ ] heroin are you on opiates
what's wrong with you i was just talking
[ __ ] to him in the garage we were right
by where you took your little pictures
we used to have that hash oil all the
time
and then
let's loop it back to
one of the videos on our i think it's
like the hollywood
smoke out or something that's when me
and you'd smoke that huge joint with
currency
josh stones raw and all that [ __ ] oh
right so it's on camera yeah that day i
told you guys what's wrong with you
[ __ ] are you on drugs
now you take us into this next part
because it just said zan addiction
that's all it says
so you you you you go for it [ __ ]
damn my [ __ ] i was [ __ ] hooked i
mean [ __ ] all right so before we go to
the
zany addiction
you know
my [ __ ] before all this was always
[ __ ] popular volume volumes there
i mean and
with you know [ __ ] old school volumes
you know the volume is with the [ __ ]
little [ __ ] none of us do but yes
there's a little v in the middle it's
the [ __ ] you know
a little blue a blue one you know
my [ __ ] was always [ __ ]
no matter what my my [ __ ] was [ __ ]
pop half a volume
and drink party terrible don't do that
[ __ ] ever please you know that was my
height you know what i mean i [ __ ] do
you still exist no no no i haven't seen
they don't have no more and volumes are
done
are you
speaking that microphone man so i always
[ __ ] you know i mean i always [ __ ]
that was my [ __ ] thing to [ __ ] do
volumes and [ __ ] drink drink beer
when did that start that [ __ ] would keep
me up [ __ ]
dirty it'll keep me up to me it was a
number
any downer to me is a [ __ ] upper you
know what i mean it's the opposite
you know so that [ __ ] would keep me up
going [ __ ] for hours bro when did
this start
[ __ ] this started [ __ ] you see the
age [ __ ]
well i mean for me popping volumes i
mean i don't know if i told you before
right
me [ __ ] with volumes
started off when i was a kid maybe about
nine or eight years old oh
the doctor would give me a [ __ ]
volume
so i'll break that down a little bit why
why the [ __ ] you were going to the
doctor so yeah
like i said it was an insurance fraud
yeah and this [ __ ] you know [ __ ] he
was telling you what
timing my back was [ __ ] up and giving
me [ __ ] mri
you would give me a volume yeah you know
i mean long story short give me a
[ __ ] volume and [ __ ] that's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's all that's how i got that
feeling about [ __ ] where the volume
was look at opiates at nine [ __ ] yeah
you know
so i mean after later on all this time
passes you know i mean [ __ ] all of a
sudden um
[ __ ]
18 18 years old and i'm [ __ ] now 19
19 no i'm talking about 19 years old
and now all of a sudden now i'm like oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] i can get these volumes
over here let me have some so now i'm
[ __ ] you know breaking half a volume
taking half a volume you're not snorting
them or anything right no so you're just
not
yeah take half a pill and i would
[ __ ] drink alcohol and that [ __ ]
would get me going and that [ __ ] get me
going good you know what i mean like
there was no [ __ ] i felt good and she
kept me up
[ __ ] you're not snoring top of the
world [ __ ] though i felt like the
[ __ ] the greatest person right you're
not doing other drugs with it no well at
the time at first no i started off like
that
now now now we're starting into the
party scene so now i'm taking half a
volume drinking beer
and we're adding now coke to the [ __ ]
thing yeah smoking crack still no no
crack's already been done i didn't [ __ ]
with crack yet so now i'm doing
drinking beer with the volume and then
ending it off with some coke oh
i mean how much time are we talking
about like a whole night all night [ __ ]
a whole night bro we're talking starting
from about six in the evening
to about [ __ ] three four in the
morning how long until the to the volume
wears off
[ __ ] bro i mean the good thing was the
volume the volume part was the thing
that always no matter what when you're
ready to crash you're ready to crash
but if you have that [ __ ] where you can
keep you can fight those are downers
though i mean oh you said it it's the
upper to you why do you think that why
do you feel like that does it to your
body i want to say maybe because i've
done stronger drugs that [ __ ] other
drugs that you know i mean the volume
like it to me it's like it's a high you
know i mean it was a high like and it
was like it's
if you take it down i mean you're
supposed to be slumped
yeah right but for me it was the
opposite that's how i feel about weed
from me that's awesome
yeah i smoke i smoke this to say awake
on long drives you know i love to wake
up yeah it's the same thing with og yeah
yeah so
so i mean my thing so anyways
you're 19 or 20 you're [ __ ] around
and i'm doing [ __ ] volumes and i'm
doing them all the way to about [ __ ]
aside i'm doing them [ __ ] for about
maybe 12 13 years old god damn damn to
the point that you're bet you're fully
addicted you know i mean
i'm not even addicted because it's just
a weekend thing yeah it was like it
wasn't even like like you just like to
do it yeah i just like to take a half a
volume every time i used to drink you're
not saying that's true it wasn't yeah to
me it wasn't like i didn't look at it
like you know but i always liked it
because to me i could drink longer you
know what i mean i could i could drink
[ __ ] like say we drink a 12-pack with
half a volume i can [ __ ] i'll drink
maybe drink 20 beers 30 beers 30 maybe
20 20. it's like coke it's like no
problem yeah exactly when i used to do
rails i could drink a fifth i could get
fifth now but it would do nothing to me
when i'm [ __ ] doing rails all night
exactly yeah yeah but the volume got me
like that it made me feel like you know
what made me feel was it easy to get oh
yeah yeah i had one of my neighbors i
just [ __ ] i pat it right there on the
spot whatever i wanted it was there i
would buy a [ __ ] every weekend i'd
buy like let me get four
boom for friday and saturday and with
for me and to share with my friends it
was perfect because i wouldn't take them
all
like i said i would take half
one full one at the most you know but
those shits will make you feel on top of
the world so 12 13 years so 12 13 years
and then after that they i couldn't get
the [ __ ] volume because they aren't
existing yeah after they started cutting
them down and they were they started
getting the other you know
did you look for something else
i tried to i was looking for it
everywhere
finally one day [ __ ] someone brought
me a [ __ ] bar of a white [ __ ] zany
bar
and all the rectangles right no this was
a bar
there were little pills correct i don't
[ __ ] with pills no no that that was a no
no this was a part like a [ __ ] you
know it looked like a bar and [ __ ]
three squares or four squares oh yeah
that's yeah that's that's what i'm
talking about i was like you know [ __ ]
it [ __ ] let me get
[ __ ] let me get a couple
anyone tell me now bro [ __ ] these are
strong i'm like man
[ __ ] that yeah well first time i started
off i took two [ __ ] bars do full
woods no no half a bar you know like i
bought oh you took two pieces i broke it
in two pieces i [ __ ] took it that was
my first one i drank some beer wait how
long sorry how long after you couldn't
find volume uh volumes anymore this was
how long after harder i wanted to say
about a year and a half oh so it wasn't
even an addiction no because i was still
getting i was still getting the volumes
but i was still getting them like now
it's like she couldn't they couldn't get
them [ __ ] like the way she got them
it was more like i only got him like
i could only sell you i get you four a
month i get you so now i'm just taking
score and it's just for me yeah they're
not i'm not sure he's nobody people are
hitting me up like he's going like [ __ ]
no i don't got nothing because their
minds but it wasn't uh like i'm still i
want to say i'm still used to drinking
with them and there's no way i'm
thinking like there's no way i'm going
to go out to another party and i'm not
going to [ __ ] have half a volume i
need it otherwise i'm not going to drink
it's [ __ ] me up i drink six beers and
i'm all [ __ ] up instead of when i take
that volume i can drink [ __ ] more
beers it was just weird so you just
liked it because you wanted to [ __ ]
chill and get [ __ ] up yeah yeah so
it's not like an addiction so once you
couldn't find you're like [ __ ] i'll just
take one whenever yeah okay cool so you
find
horrible asanics
take take the the piece i take two what
happens to you i drink beer
[ __ ]
hit smash boom down
out so a real downer actually hit you
yeah i was [ __ ] out like [ __ ] like
if something like
i fought it i fought it for about an
hour and a half
but [ __ ] no i couldn't [ __ ] find it
how many beers you drink with that first
one that first night no i must have
drank about six seven beers oh so you
were getting [ __ ] up oh yeah yeah but
with the volume they wouldn't do that
but with this one it just got me down
made me [ __ ] just like to the worst
boom did you like that [ __ ] though
i liked it but i said hey [ __ ]
half of a pill got me that way you know
what [ __ ] no i gotta take
half of a square
so i'm like how the [ __ ] do you bust
that down wow i got broke up i broke up
one of the squares because there's four
both one square and that one square the
[ __ ] the
when i had one square i [ __ ]
broke that [ __ ] in half the best just
that would be the best i can well with
with alcohol oh yeah you know how that's
so dangerous so i kind of like i kind of
try to level it out like the way the
volume would work so i took that
and that started working for me it
started working for me like oh [ __ ] okay
i can still drink on it yeah it was
still working for me you know and
[ __ ] no before you know it [ __ ] just
happened you know one year
i'd say like about maybe one year doing
it two years like little half little
pieces
and then just one year [ __ ] just [ __ ]
just some [ __ ] went down and you know i
went to some [ __ ] and i just said you
know what
[ __ ] it how much longer from when you
first got him until you said [ __ ] it
about two years after no
three years after so you're like 35.
ah no
no
actually bro i'm not gonna lie [ __ ]
this was uh from now this
it's been uh it's gonna be
it's gonna be five years oh your mouth
is
it's just five years okay so
[ __ ] all that 13-year [ __ ] later let's
let's let's let's skip ahead another 10
years i'm talking from
2006. you did him until 16. i did them
all the way from like 2006 to those all
the way to like 2014 gotcha so that gap
right there is what we're talking about
okay that didn't make sense to me now it
does yeah so
this brings us up to speed and
bam and it's meagle are you on drugs
[ __ ] and talking [ __ ] yeah
because i was like yo what the [ __ ]
wrong with you i told you the same thing
16 times you do that anyway but this
time i'm like are you really [ __ ]
with me this time are you not retaining
are you on drugs what are you on heroin
what the [ __ ] wrong with you yeah boom
so i when you said [ __ ] it we won't get
into why when you said [ __ ] it
was 2015.
almost no
16 sir because i moved here in 16 this
[ __ ] happened like six months after i
got here yeah yeah i was [ __ ] sixteen
five years ago six so some [ __ ] went
down you know what i mean we'll leave it
at that but and you started taking that
one [ __ ] taking full ones and i
started
to start going full at it but [ __ ]
taking about i think i i was all about
about maybe three bars three bars four
ones
three bars
bars
taking with
with i mean
so i started off with
with you know one bar next you know one
in half two bars next to you know you
know when you're taking the chargers
they bar the whole thing yeah not just
the square no you started off with a
quarter of a square yeah to a whole
square now you take a one and a half you
know after i mean before all that i
started taking one whole one maybe a
whole full maybe a hopeful square and i
would drink with it
it would get me a little more sloppier
i'm not going to lie i was a more
sloppier
then it started [ __ ] i started taking
more
to where i reached the point where i
literally stopped drinking alcohol and
just started [ __ ] popping pills
[Music]
so i started [ __ ] thinking about
[ __ ]
i started off with
one and a half bars two bars three bars
i mean i wouldn't [ __ ] recommend
anybody to [ __ ] take no one two bars
none i mean take none [ __ ] aside
i'm gonna say i was [ __ ] i'm [ __ ]
blessed to be here but
i would you know just i'm pretty sure
people are hearing me out there and
they're [ __ ] hearing me say that i
took one two three bars
[ __ ] that just let you guys know [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] don't [ __ ] take no bars
i mean [ __ ] i'm lucky to be here
straight up straight the [ __ ] up i'm
lucky to be here still you know what i
mean
so i wouldn't want anybody out there to
even try to [ __ ]
to even reach that level it's [ __ ]
very dangerous man yeah and you were
taking other things too yeah exactly
yeah and i was actually taking other
pills too i [ __ ] started [ __ ] on
perky sets as well so i started taking
perky sets and then mixing it up with
the xanax you know what i mean
and it was [ __ ] it was some
some [ __ ] roller coaster she's not
telling me you little [ __ ]
we were chilling every single day and
every day i'm just like why are you so
[ __ ] high
i would say that like yo are you you
baby ass lungs what's up with you we
just took like a half a gram dab and
you're dead
maybe times like what's wrong with this
[ __ ] i just assumed we were all
really high
were you not telling anybody
no actually i wasn't yeah i mean there's
a few people that that knew about it but
i was not i was not letting anybody know
about it yeah i had no [ __ ] ideas at
all especially him you know i didn't
want him to know so i was like [ __ ] that
i mean [ __ ]
nope
it was it was bad bro it was bad you
know what i mean
i would have [ __ ] held you down it
was so bad where i'm gonna tell you this
right now i'm
they say why i'm so lucky to be here is
because you know there was that one time
where you know the video where i'm
trying to get these i'm trying to get
these pills and i'm like [ __ ] somebody
again finally somebody gives them to me
you know what i mean and um
i would always start off with the half a
bar
and then take a full bar well when i
took that half bar
it was like
like
i [ __ ] took some
it was [ __ ] something just
strong
like rather i took that that half of a
bar within
20 to 30 minutes
i literally couldn't even see right i
was literally just like i felt like
i looked literally like a heroin addict
like that's why i pictured myself it was
like a dream that i seen myself in
and i see myself you know just
everywhere couldn't talk i'm slurring
everywhere just learning my words
the next day i just that's it i blank
out
talking to people i blank out
i wake up the next day
and i'm still slurring and i'm still
[ __ ]
like
i'm talking like if i just she's like if
i just had pops and pills and this was
from just a half of a pill
and this wasn't xanax do you this was a
xanax it was supposed to be a green from
a new person it was supposed to be a
green bar right
i mean i don't know i mean it was i'm
not gonna say it was from a new person
but [ __ ] it i'm not blaming it on them
they got it from the streets too we you
know that's the way it goes [ __ ]
i know i know homeboy didn't make it
himself
you know but
so the next day i [ __ ] woke up and i
was still like [ __ ] loaded like
[ __ ] just still like [ __ ] like i
could feel it you know and
[ __ ] just in a [ __ ] up mood bad mood
just [ __ ] crazy like
and
someone told me down
i'm all damn i still have four bars and
a half how is that i bought five bars
and i'm so [ __ ] up with a half a bar
and that's when someone told me hey
throw that [ __ ] in some water
see if it [ __ ] and explain why if it
[ __ ] explain what it is if it's
[ __ ] if it opens up like a book and
i'm like threw in some water i'm like
god damn that [ __ ] just what does it
mean popped up in layers so that means
it was [ __ ] it was pressed you know
what i mean so if you for everyone out
there if you are addicted to pills what
you just said to test uphill if you get
a batch throw a pill in water and if it
starts to open and not dissolve yes if
it starts to open that means
it looks like a book like it starts to
fray [ __ ] press [ __ ] means it's fake
so what do you think it was
well it was some [ __ ] fentanyl some
[ __ ] in here i mean i'm lucky to be here
it was [ __ ] some deadly [ __ ] if i
would have took what i normally would
take
my one pill and a half if i would have
took that that night
i [ __ ] wouldn't be here guaranteed i
wouldn't be here
you know for some reason i just that day
i decided to take a half
and it hit so fast that i didn't have
the time to take the rest of it
that's how [ __ ] local was
so you know i mean
there was some local [ __ ] that's why for
i highly recommend
i would never take no pills out there
from anybody in the streets because
i'm telling you man [ __ ] you can't blame
the dude for getting the pills on the
streets
because i get it it's like a chain
reaction out there the pills are out
there yeah but
[ __ ] no man i would not [ __ ] with them
what's the last time it's quite good i
was gonna say the same thing they make
you slow down
oh no the question was the last time you
did it you know the last time we did it
was i believe uh we went to uh went to
this coffee shop right i don't know the
video i was talking about it's on our
channel it's called like the hollywood
coffee shop hollywood smoke out or
something it's me you and the currencies
in the video josh is in the video
there's a bunch of people at a coffee
shop yeah yeah
yeah that was all [ __ ] up i remember
that [ __ ] so that's the weed that day i
couldn't get percocets
i mean i couldn't get um um zannings at
the time so i had percocets so i had
popped one percocet and i'm like [ __ ]
this you know i mean
you know because the percentage it's a
whole different thing you know i mean
one's a [ __ ] painkiller one's a
[ __ ] muscle relaxer or tranquil
tranquilizer and [ __ ] you know what i
mean so
you know i'm like [ __ ] i don't feel the
same so i took another percocet two
percocets next thing you know i'm
getting ready to you know head out to go
pick you up
and dick my boy just happens to caught
the last minute says hey i got you
something i got two of them right here
and i'm like [ __ ] let me get him xanax
yes and i got two so i [ __ ] we pulled up
to his pet
[ __ ] got the two zans i take [ __ ] one
right there i leave so now i'm on two
perks one zen
so we get to the [ __ ]
the spot it's the spot we parked and
everything full and i'm [ __ ] i'm
loaded and [ __ ] and
next thing you know i get there [ __ ] it
pop the next one
so now i'm [ __ ] sneaky little [ __ ]
i'm on a roller coaster you know i'm
like [ __ ] you know
up down up down and i'm [ __ ] lit
so
[ __ ]
tell them what happened
tell them what happened we had [ __ ]
you know we rolled up i have rolled up a
big joint everybody right check this
joint we have a gigantic i remember is i
hit that [ __ ] joint i [ __ ] hit
that [ __ ] so hard
i laid it out this is on camera
and i give the joint to you know him or
whatever i give it to currency whatever
and
bro my [ __ ] heart just like
double skips triple skips
i can't even breathe bro i'm just like
oh what the [ __ ] i'm like so close bro
where i'm surprised i didn't think
but i [ __ ] felt
like this is it
die right here
and i'm like [ __ ] like you couldn't
catch your breath like you had not even
my breath deals my heart that just when
i boom boom like
you know [ __ ] two perks two zones
[ __ ] you know i'm [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] tripping you know i mean i'm
[ __ ] like damn this [ __ ] hit hard
i thought that was it
well
as you can see it wasn't him
but so we leave you drive
[ __ ] you drove yeah for sure you
drove i'm good so that's the last that's
when you decided yo i thought i was
gonna [ __ ] die in front of everybody
i'm gonna stop doing these pills no
actually so we took off that night and
then [ __ ] uh i drove home
went home
crashed out
so like i said when i crashed out [ __ ]
bro
at night i had some [ __ ]
some [ __ ] you know some crazy ass
dream you know i mean where you know to
me
i feel like part of it it's like part of
like my ancestors that are bringing this
[ __ ] to me and they [ __ ]
you know they feed me this and you know
they they always help me out in some way
so i feel like you know
they they came you know and they they
gave me a message but they sent it
through another way you know i mean
it was like
it it's like it was just a dream that
i've always been scared of since i've
been a kid
and it just it came back to me
and this time it was more like
i dominate the dream like [ __ ] this like
i was over this [ __ ] dream uh-huh
like there's always one dream that i
always [ __ ] wake up in the night
where it just [ __ ] was just a
nightmare where you changed it or
something [ __ ] you up you know what i
mean you changed it that night oh that
night everything changed and it was
weird for the good for the better yeah
and it was like i felt like if i was
dead and something woke me up
and to try to scare me and
i woke up actually out of [ __ ] like
being dead
and then you know [ __ ] i woke up the
next morning so and you're trying to
woke up the next morning it wasn't the
same no it wasn't the same type of like
it wasn't the same type of waking up
like you normally wake up it was like i
woke up
and just like hopped out of bed like
hopped out of my house actually
i was sleeping in my living room and i
hopped out of my couch
i hopped out of my couch and i said [ __ ]
like
something in me like got me up
like get the [ __ ] up now like you know
you just you were dead or something
and so you're saying you had this
recurring dream and this time you
changed it to where it was you won
finally yeah and you woke up and stopped
doing pills yeah and i just woke up and
i said you know what i'm done i'm done
doing pills and i'm gonna tell you they
[ __ ] the pills were like i never seen
myself ever even leaving pills
there was one time when i would get my
pills and i would be like
you know i love this [ __ ] so much that
i'll never stop doing this [ __ ] i know i
won't because i love it
and it was there was a point where i
literally loved pills more than weed and
beer
that's it it was just pills that's it
that was my thing i loved it so much did
you go through with trolls
oh [ __ ] go for it and tell him what
happened
yeah yeah jerk
i mean the first week
it was cool second week it was
i got cool sorry after the second to
third week
it [ __ ] come to my house it just
stand bro that's when i started the
whole withdrawals because i did a cold
turkey second to third week
third weeks was when i started getting
the withdrawals it didn't hit right away
because
i think that's how much that's how much
i had in my [ __ ] that it was like
you're still okay yeah
yeah my body was had so much in in it
that it was still [ __ ] maintaining it
you know what i mean like i will still
be able to handle it and then my first
week i was like man i was even bragging
to people
man i stopped taking pills last week i
don't even take them [ __ ] that i'm cool
second weekend
third week cool after the third week
damn [ __ ] that's crazy i never heard
of that before is that normal
well i thought it kicks in immediately
right when you stopped like
it didn't for me it took a minute to
kick in it took me about i want to say
not maybe three weeks someone say maybe
two weeks
or yeah two weeks that's when it just
boom
horrible that's it bro i was on a
[ __ ]
that's it it was just what happened
dealt with it well you came to my house
oh happy birthday bro i [ __ ] felt
like um
like [ __ ] this big [ __ ] guilt
the biggest [ __ ] guilt ever like
everything you ever did in your life
just [ __ ] hits you everything
your
everything you ever did that you [ __ ]
did bad [ __ ] hits you
you know i mean you're just [ __ ] like
damn bro like i'm not gonna lie
literally
at a point where you're like [ __ ] bro
like
like
maybe i shouldn't be here
and that's where i feel like you know
where people say [ __ ] how you know like
you know suicide and [ __ ] happens you
know what i mean
because i literally felt at that point
you know what i mean like there was a
time where i went to
went to his house and you know he had a
balcony
and i mean he didn't even know what's
going on
and i'm outside his balcony alone like
i'll just get up and open his [ __ ]
bucket and go out there and i was just
like [ __ ] i'm looking i'm looking down
i'm looking up
like [ __ ] maybe i should just throw
myself right here off this [ __ ]
balcony and i'm gonna be [ __ ] good
you know what i mean like
damn
i'm thinking i won't die i'm gonna get
hurt bad where i'm not gonna feel bad
for anything no more i'm gonna feel good
you know i mean anything bad you've done
you're not gonna feel bad no more you
know
you're gonna feel good after you do this
yeah it was [ __ ] some trippy ass [ __ ]
how long did that go like that for
[ __ ] i want to say it took me about
six months
yeah well it was horrible
it was [ __ ] the worst man
that's why like
[ __ ] man i wouldn't recommend anybody
and you just did pills willpower there
was nothing like willpower and just [ __ ]
it bro tie your [ __ ] balls in the
knot and i raised him good i mean from a
child i raised you right strong i mean
you know we all got it in us we all got
in this i believe everybody gots it in
them there's no such thing as
you know you're gonna [ __ ]
you you're gonna you're not gonna come
out of it you're gonna come out of it
because you everybody has it in them you
just gotta [ __ ] use that [ __ ]
[ __ ] willpower in you
it's in you bro it's
there's no such thing as you don't
everybody has it around there's no such
thing as
you know wow i was raised this way i
never got learned i never learned about
this and not [ __ ]
i mean i believe that's how powerful the
mind is
and you know [ __ ] it it [ __ ]
i just kept after that you know i just
started just
taking care of myself started you know
what i mean started you know
talking to my own self by you know
trying to you know figure out who i am
and you know
where i come from and
snap out of that [ __ ] just put your
mind in something else that you know you
don't want to [ __ ]
you don't want to [ __ ] you don't want
to put yourself in because you mean when
you get done when you know when you're
doing pills
everything's just like a [ __ ]
delusion man everything [ __ ] seems
easy to you you [ __ ] waste money and
i could tell you i remember that time
trip to walmart [ __ ] i'll walk out of
walmart with [ __ ]
eight hundred dollars seven hundred
dollars
and i'll come home and i'll be like what
the [ __ ] is this am i gonna be like well
you said you're gonna fix this you said
you're going to do this you're going to
do that you're going to do this i'm like
[ __ ] bro
i'm [ __ ] going to do none of that
[ __ ]
so you're [ __ ] delusional thinking
you feel that good do you still miss it
uh you know i'm
i'll be honest with you i don't miss it
but i do think about it you know what i
mean i guess
i don't i don't want to say i don't want
to call it missing it but
you know i think about it and sometimes
when i'm saying
[ __ ]
well i mean if if i was still in this
like you know what i'm doing right now
just on zanz or being loaded
like
how would you be
and i'd be like [ __ ] no i'd be [ __ ]
probably making a [ __ ] fool out of
myself yeah you know what i mean yeah
like because now i could see
there's videos where actually you know
my girl were recording and she showed me
like look look at you in the restaurant
look at the way you're [ __ ] eating a
[ __ ] taco and [ __ ] and i'm [ __ ]
i'm literally with my eyes closed and
i'm eating it yeah and i'm like
just you did a good job of hiding the
[ __ ] and we never once actually i never
once saw that [ __ ] before uh i never saw
you fall asleep like that
you probably seen it but you probably
thought i was on edibles because that's
what i would tell him
oh i [ __ ] took some medicals right
now i just wouldn't believe it always
says this would take a lot of airports
yeah so you know i do remember this
[ __ ] falling asleep at the table
i do remember that but we were eating
ourselves so and i would tell this food
that i would take oh yeah i mean because
i had a lot of rso and i would always
look i got some i'll try to give it to
him i did give it to him a couple of
times but you know i wouldn't take it
and i would tell this guy that i was on
our song [ __ ] you said i just did a
gram yes i remember that right [ __ ]
and i'd be [ __ ] loaded bro [ __ ]
straight up loaded on pills this is what
i'm about to ask what what's so
different about the rso that makes sense
so it's the most concentrated thing you
can ever think of in your possible life
existence
it's the strongest form of weed you
could possibly have it is
medicinal it is [ __ ]
it's the nectar
of
everything what's different is it the
process
i mean it's really it's everything it's
[ __ ] it's all the old flat matter
[ __ ]
and you make a little bit more move it
up to you okay
so i mean [ __ ]
[ __ ] alright so [ __ ] bro that's slower
i want to say [ __ ] that shit's
[ __ ]
the best bro helps out with [ __ ]
everything bro this man knows how to
make it i asked him break it down it's
the best
what i said i mean you want to make it
what is it everyone what is this like
what is it it's just
all the plant matter like of all the
leaves yes so you have a powder i
started making it a little different i
started adding all the [ __ ] you know
the [ __ ] nugs and everything a little
bit
more
stronger you know what i mean so if you
have a pound of weed how much rs are you
gonna get so he can go [ __ ] [ __ ] let's
see [ __ ] pound a week a pound of week
processed all the way down to the oil
[ __ ] syringe
rso [ __ ] you're only gonna get about
maybe two ounces two and a half
okay
of the oil yeah damn so how much is that
an oil like is that a lot look at grams
like this [ __ ] okay that's a lot right
okay but you only need a tiny little dab
of this [ __ ] rice grains
yeah rice cream and you dab it no you
eat it you could dab it
we've dabbed it it was disgusting no no
actually the one i was making with the
bugs it was actually you could dab and
it was still it wasn't tasting bad
i mean
of course now of course
now of course yeah
back then what's different about it
though like the r the rosin the resin
and all this [ __ ]
i think i just think it's just [ __ ] i
mean i mean i'm gonna be honest with you
nobody to this date knows [ __ ] the
whole [ __ ] i mean like nobody discovered
most of this [ __ ] plan you know i
mean so
it's not like [ __ ] we know truly but
i mean
yeah to me i think it
i just think to me what it does is um
it
to me it starts up the cabinetry system
in the in somebody i mean it's just like
start it up boom
once you get that whole cabinetry system
started
in your system it
bro it's like you got
[ __ ] who knows what the [ __ ] happens but
a lot of [ __ ] happens to the body you
know what i mean so with the artist so
what i would use it for was to [ __ ]
to sleep and [ __ ] you know i mean people
who can't sleep that's what i was using
it for mm-hmm i mean [ __ ]
who [ __ ] just tastes like regular wax
and you just eat a piece
it's just like tar black
oh and i mean the best thing with our
soul was really it's it's for like chemo
people people who have
chemo
the easiest way to sleep and couldn't
eat was a documentary called again what
is it called
sanjay guy right he did the documentary
on rso
you don't talk about the the guy that
all right for everybody that has google
and the internet and memory uh
just google it
huh
it's an interview
it's an interview he explains rso to the
[ __ ] t you can find it on google
because we are not going to do it
who's that it's the doctor
uh i don't want to miss [ __ ] his name up
some guy
just google it rso rso explained no rick
simpson explains it too i know
you have red ass wine libs
alright so it's it's for people going
through chemo it helps with [ __ ] i
don't want to say too much well i just
get [ __ ] [ __ ] on on youtube and like
yo don't you release them all for
information even though it's freely on
google no actually well no what it does
is [ __ ] it helps people to sleep and
to eat you know what i mean yeah so for
cancer patients it stops like the nausea
yeah and it helps you [ __ ] get you
[ __ ] up and you find i would highly
recommend
anybody who's going to chemo [ __ ]
take rso you know what i mean it helps a
lot it helps a lot you know i mean even
if you're having trouble
um sleeping and i take it for regular
for like a month remember the little
right screens it's just to write it's
like taking cbd except you better get
ready if you take too much get [ __ ] a
literal rice right
it's you will [ __ ] you up
yeah you could start off with the rice
cream and you take a rice cream maybe
three times a day
be careful and uh you know what i mean
well it's because he's saying be careful
because the way i was making i was
making it a whole lot stronger
yeah with the buds and stuff sounds a
whole lot stranger
he's a lot he's a jerk he had these
capsules he tells me to fill it up i've
told the story before he tells me to
fill it up and i fill it up and then i
take it and i get super [ __ ]
violently spinning high within 40
minutes right after i went to counter or
whatever it's called the super nice bro
you literally took [ __ ] hold you said
fill it up i take it throw up everywhere
spins my whole night's done my homies
leave my house it's cause you weren't
used to it yet stop see with the rso you
gotta create a tolerance i was no what
happened you don't remember what you
said rosie mindy do you remember what he
said when i took too much rso what he
said my fault was well you're not
supposed to fill it all the way up oh
yeah
not both sides
he said fill it up sorry
what build it up
half a capsule no he felt both sides bro
but you said fill it up no
you don't feel the back side of it why
wouldn't you what i mean why wouldn't
you fill up the whole capsule when you
sir said fill it up
no no you had to admit it you got to
admit it your words may be misleading no
no i didn't mean that though
but that's what you said you you
actually took it the wrong way hey can
you fill up that cup for me and you can
bring it halfway i'm gonna go well yeah
it's like it's like okay fill up the
fill up the cup and this will fill up
the cup and the cap and put the cap over
it filled up don't do that
that's what i deal with guys
this is the [ __ ] i deal with
he thinks he's right
the [ __ ]
drink that bee
i should have went to the bathroom when
you guys went to the bathroom because i
really got to go to the bathroom and i
have another question and i feel like
we're going to just keep it going and
ranting and ranting
oh yeah the new catchphrase instead of
saying you have to go pee it's like oh
i'm gonna go touch my dick real quick
because it's funnier and i made it up
because the other day we rolled a joint
and oh gee i'm like i'm a light he goes
no let me go to the bathroom real quick
and i'll be right back then i said let
me go take a leak real quick yeah that's
what he said i said so basically you're
saying hey let me go touch my dick i'll
be right back to touch that joint and
i'm like damn something write that down
i wrote it down because i thought it was
funny
so for everyone out there i have to
touch my dick real quick means oh i have
to pee
girls please please use it please use it
too
if mindy got up i'm gonna touch my dick
real quick like that was [ __ ] funny
who says that i like it so i have to pee
so bad i'm trying to take my mind off it
how much time's left like three minutes
is it really
uh let's do a little card change
okay let's go
i'm gonna get you back watch i'll get
you watch i got one for you that's what
you're gonna say after that right
yeah okay i got you got you
got you
i'm gonna call it ass mister i'm saying
the word as is a s
mr is mr
i'm saying remember it that way because
you've asked me 66 times
asmr yeah as mister in your head
asmr
asmr yep that's when you do this
[ __ ] hey how are you girls do it on
only fans
and they're like they're like naked and
they do this
click click with their nails right
it's like a sexual thing oh
but people like it because it sounds
sick as [ __ ]
so they want like do a joint rolling one
might be sick
we basically do asmr when we do our
montages and marty adds like
essentially we do
because the sounds are so close
[ __ ] sure okay like if a plane goes
by here
i'm saying when you're listening to it
on youtube it's basically the same thing
because we're putting fake sounds and
crazy shots mr [ __ ] yep the ass mr [ __ ]
got it you got it credit card
you got it
oh [ __ ] i'm gonna move this okay let's
put it right here all right wait a
minute you say i have [ __ ] pink lips
no purple my lips [ __ ] you don't like
wine lips i told you that i like you can
wind it like right here
there
no like
on the inside of your lip
yeah right there
see
yeah you're fine
give me that [ __ ] it's fine now
oh i gotta smoke this whole cannabis cup
i forgot this is your joint [ __ ] out of
here
okay oh look now
[ __ ] white lips
henry you look like a gangster
[Music]
clarence parents have a real good
marriage
what the [ __ ] you guys talking about i
hate mile
oh remember i told you i've only seen it
once and i only saw pieces
hey you you saw that [ __ ] are you ready
is you ready
um is you ready can i tell you that you
have peanuts on your lips
you have peanut crumbs all over your
lips on your lips
leave it in [ __ ] out of here stupid
would you tell marty earlier marty if
you like breathing you're going to cut
that part out that's what you said right
it was funny he knows right martial
night of pockets
he just shook night of podcasting
what the
[ __ ] nope
anything oh geez the paul rubins of
podcasting you're pee wee herman
all right
pee wee herman
second time in a row i brought up pv
here
i just [ __ ] with him hey he's cool man
he's cool man
all right pee wee herman
so you were all you were all strawberry
on your acid trip and the principal told
you to go home
yeah actually was you pulled the
strawberry yeah
lean to the side yeah it actually stuck
to the side like like a soldier with my
hands to the side leaning sideways you
just watched too much stuff choosing
just stuck
and i seen everything level when she was
talking to me i [ __ ] seen her
straight
and she's like that's incredible [ __ ]
yesterday get the [ __ ] out of here
she sent me home which was cool you know
i didn't get
you go to jail and then you said that
she was your ancestor
yeah
i'm [ __ ] mulan
and eddie murphy's
this [ __ ] guy
oh i think a heroin slam's coming
hey you felt it
if you want to dress like me you want to
dress like me all right you're going to
[ __ ] i'm going to [ __ ] with you hold
on me i always wanted to be like daddy
no he says he's been little remember
used to always wear my boots
[Laughter]
on my hands
remember i used to always get mad
because i saw him take my boots off and
he used to dress like rufio from hook
and i'm like yo yo son they're going to
make fun you know what he's going to
have to learn this on his own and then
i'd go like that
get out of here kid
he'd walk off to school with his
backpack his jan sport i'd always made
the best i did the best for him as a
child
jansporting ben davis
yeah all right
how did you know he's gonna end up at
the gang
i came ben davis every day he thought it
would be good right really no that's not
true and carter
he loves he loves his daddy when he was
a kid he was a
a dodger i mean not dodge fan a san
francisco giants fan
as a kid used to rock the sf had a lot
and he was a niner fan too it was crazy
at the time when he was little we lost
to san francisco
he was upset
so
where's this guy
i'm a package fan no don't bro i love
the stuff i love california teams i love
the night i love san francisco well of
course you're from california
i appreciate the raiders he loves oh he
loves the raiders i appreciate them
because they're from california oh
they're from vegas now
i'm still from girl oh [ __ ] out of here
oh she's a rams fan at heart all right
let's move on uh so so far we talked
about your asses stories you stealing
your neighbor's car uh mexico trips what
else illegal gambling in your garage
let's see uh on a
mexico mindy fight story damn these
notes are great and then you
accidentally taking [ __ ] fentanyl
and
lying to me so if anyone wants to see
this full too [ __ ] up there's a video
out there it's called hollywood
something
it's a smoking gigantic joint really i
haven't even seen that video
i don't watch no none of the videos he's
so camera bro he doesn't watch any of
our [ __ ] because he's in it
it's insane kind of [ __ ] is that
brad pitt you just want your own [ __ ]
you're too cool and [ __ ] no i don't
watch your own [ __ ] well i don't watch
nothing i really don't even my own [ __ ]
i don't watch
even your home videos
i don't
as a kid when i facetime you remember
like when it's facetime he puts his
thumb over it oh i don't want to see
myself
he always says that he always says that
he's like i hate me
and goody juniors starts punching the
air cuba gooding jr
all right let's get on to the next topic
the real topic okay
[ __ ] off what if we did an episode where
me and you said nothing that was true
for three [ __ ] fans are just confused
by the way i barely met this
[ __ ] like eight years ago
so none of this is real by the way
continue um everybody used to beat you
at mortal kombat every day and you
support all the combinations of all your
nickels and trade them for me for
quarters
no don't mean either
all right under the next thing ready on
to the last question last question thank
you all for being here if you've sat
here through this [ __ ] of us just
talking [ __ ] this full starting riots
[ __ ] selling fake acid to
[ __ ] stealing neighbors cars
you lived a great life
ready
it's funny because all this is a movie
this is all i love it i love it because
i think about the [ __ ] i didn't go
take away the guns and it's a little
less shooty
and yeah about that you're not gonna get
the asmr of you inhaling i know what you
were doing you went like this
i saw it
you can't even put your lips right there
not the [ __ ] cherry the lip go like
this
[ __ ] out here do it i could hear hello
wow put your lip on i just did it
he smokes the [ __ ] mic all the time
let's see let's see do it again man put
your lip on it
put it right here on your side
get away from me
i'm gonna call cps
i'm calling gps bro
[Laughter]
i'm gonna flip the table t-bone you
ready last question
last question
[ __ ] you
talk to me
[Laughter]
all right
are you ready
last question
all of your kids are now almost 18.
they're almost done
you guys are almost done yeah what's the
next step for life's
og's life after kids
because you're gonna have them still but
once they're like 18 they're getting
that age they're gonna also wanna move
out this one's gonna move down it's
gonna be a chain reaction like oh she
moved out
i'm getting my own apartment too yeah
that's tight and it's gonna keep going
and then you guys are gonna just be
chilling
what's the plan
five generations
the youngest one 17
my youngest one seventeen seventeen ten
my boy oh he's sixteen yeah
oh i thought he was seventeen
oh okay so within the next two years
eventually something's gonna start
moving around someone will get a job
some will start going to school someone
will do this well no don't get me wrong
you know a few of them do go to school
i'm saying full
have hope for yourself you don't be a
generic mexican family very funny
everyone lives together
because i mean think about it the way
[ __ ] [ __ ] how expensive [ __ ] is out
there there ain't no [ __ ] way they
could [ __ ] make it out there right
now i mean just i mean i'm pretty sure
[ __ ] out of here don't give me that
[ __ ] look [ __ ] one bedroom
apartment cost us like two thousand
dollars now and [ __ ] how the [ __ ] you
know yeah you go get a job and you're
gonna stay dedicated to just [ __ ]
work and you're gonna be a robot you go
to work
and back home every day not everybody
can be a drug dealer jerk
they're saving money right now and going
to school that's what i'm saying they're
saving money so when they one day move
out when that day happens
when that day happens it's my question
what are your [ __ ] [ __ ] oh okay
my bad [ __ ]
how could i be more clear i said it no
what do you mean oh geez life after kids
once they all eventually move out what
is the plan [ __ ] my plans is [ __ ]
just to [ __ ] move somewhere else
[ __ ]
away from [ __ ] dumb people
straight up you know i mean [ __ ] stupid
just make houses for the homeless i just
want to move away from dumb people i
mean i'm gonna make shirts out of this
[ __ ]
my thing is stickers for sure i mean
[ __ ] who doesn't want [ __ ] peace and
quiet right of course that's the whole
[ __ ] point so that's my next move bro
you know i mean if i move if i'm gonna
move out of my if i'm gonna move out of
my location if i move out the hood i'll
make sure i'm gonna move out the [ __ ]
hood yeah that's what i'm gonna go move
to another hood
or another [ __ ] [ __ ] out of here bro
we're not [ __ ] you know what i mean a
level though okay are you gonna move
where it's [ __ ] literally call out
the hood when you move are you gonna
move where you [ __ ] drive down your
street to liquor store and it's a hood
[ __ ] out of here fool you didn't move
out the hood [ __ ] you're still
living in the hood are you gonna move
away from the mic more when you move out
the hood okay so nobody can hear
anything
where the [ __ ] out of there yo work out
when i'm out the hood that's how you're
talking i've asked well you know when i
speak loud enough where it's [ __ ]
hurting i'm gonna start doing again
i'm gonna start hitting you in the shin
again every time i hit you in the [ __ ]
that just means going like this oh my
dad oh [ __ ] remember my dad said
that he's going to talk
it's okay man it's okay
it's gonna be all right so you want to
move away from dumb people yeah so you
still want to uh skyrise
i do you still want to move into the
condos
no no you know what no i'm not into the
sky rise no one thought you said that
you said you wanted to well that was no
that was a
maybe yeah you know i thought about it
but you know what nah sky rise is not
really my [ __ ] thing no more i think
i want to move maybe you should change
your mind
i just a month ago
we were just talking about houses i want
a condo like well you know what yeah
because
well i mean because first of all
i thought i would want a condo because
[ __ ] it or you know [ __ ] up uh
whatever apartment or whatever but yeah
you know what i mean
but not you know i mean it's
i don't think it's
i mean actually for me being to your
[ __ ] to your couple your spots right
i mean [ __ ] i didn't care i really
didn't like the way the fight called
there's so many fools yes yes well
there's some places i mean in reality i
mean you're just moving to a same
type of environment
but just more like uh
i don't know i thought about it more
like [ __ ] i feel more like i'm i think
i'm more like a it's like a jail cell or
like a prison
it's like a dorm room yeah yeah i get it
so you know i thought about that that's
the vibe of a part of buildings i don't
think i want to [ __ ] live in those
skyrises yeah but some of them what are
they [ __ ] yeah you know i'm saying
some of them downtown you have the floor
like that's what i'm saying like the
penthouses where they have the whole
floor yeah it's a one big space at the
top of a building that's it's hard oh
you know what i haven't seen one those
are tight those are cool but they're
very expensive but you have your own
elevator
all right to go up to your only your
apartment it's [ __ ] cool some of that
shit's really sick all right but besides
besides that i'll be honest i've [ __ ]
i've never seen one of those
[ __ ] okay well what about this
besides that say it's five years from
now
all your kids moved out our company's up
and running
if you're obviously over a millionaire
chilling what are you doing
besides playing games all day what are
you doing what are you gonna do to
occupy your time
[ __ ]
you how to do your own [ __ ] play more
games oh you [ __ ]
this please tell this fool to get on
twitch put a shirt on but please tell
fools to get on twitch this will play
shirtless video games for seven hours a
day my ass
it's more like an hour but still every
time i call you it's this
what's up me head
oh what's up nice shirt oh nice oh yeah
and then that's it oh it died what's up
bull
what happened
to this match
i'm not lying mindy laughed a little
because she knows look at it she's dying
because she knows the truth
if i added up all the phone calls of our
life
eighty percent of it was me waiting for
your ass to [ __ ] join the
conversation and that's not not true
every time i call you at work you know
you just call me back you answer have
the rest of your meeting on your lap
helpful but just call a bike call me
back
hold on eight minutes later i've only
hung up twice
yeah i'm playing the [ __ ] game
just hang up i mean look
my thing is like [ __ ] i get i get like i
get home from work i get like maybe an
hour to play a game
and you know [ __ ] if that hour i get
to play a game and you know i get that
feeling where i'm [ __ ]
smoking some [ __ ] you went
right over my question
i don't think it's it's pretty cool
right there's two questions okay
what was your question man
how come you always just tell me to call
me back
you leave me on [ __ ] eight-minute
meetings and [ __ ] you said i'm just
trying my game yeah oh but what does
this mean
dude i was playing a game what do you
mean you were saying at work you
answered and you're like and then we
talked about three minutes you go well
let me finish this meeting
you're in a meeting yeah well dude we
have a lot of meetings at work i know
but just call me back
no today we're talking about ideas and
he goes oh but i'm with a vendor
somebody was sitting through a whole
conversation of me just talking [ __ ]
about nothing
and you all but hold on let me finish
some [ __ ] up i'll call you right back
you're with someone someone's trying to
sell something you know what i thought
he had something important to say so i
gotta just speak do it you know he gets
you know ever since he was small he used
to get mad when i don't listen to him so
i gotta listen to him now you know he
calls me and i gotta just pay attention
to him because he gets pretty upset
i know he does you know you never listen
to me
you know
like i'm listening to you
straight up
i remember now that's crazy i remember
now
weird
weird
remember oh you know what you probably
don't you probably don't you're a little
boy
you're probably too young not a core
memory yet but this fool used to always
do this to me
i was like what is that spiderman
spiderman it was so cool man that was
cool
he said roll up to me with heelys
balance remember
i would say you'd leave the bar
on heelys it was so sick
it was my son
um what's up man
so that was my question you just move
away from dumb people i kind of
actually these are good answers these
are all good answers i mean you know
what's good answers yeah i mean not
moving from double before when you're
trying to put down my people where it is
it is what it is but [ __ ] in my i
want to you know
to move out leaving my environment
my environment my lifestyle the way i
live
what i'm used to you know because i'm
not gonna lie i'm pretty sure my
neighbors they live a good [ __ ] life
because they're not [ __ ] you know
it's no [ __ ] or having anybody come
and knock at the doors and [ __ ] have
to hear [ __ ] you know i mean
so no it's me it for me it's like i'm
leaving my environment that you know uh
environment that i've always i'm used to
but it's just like that's it done
like you know what i mean like
yeah of course i'm gonna have to come
back to it because you know i still got
you know
my mom's pad and my mom's house and it's
just starting to
be back move course i'm just still my
[ __ ] you know but i'm gone i don't
have to worry about
coming home back to that you know what i
mean for sure because it's like no
matter what like whenever you know
you're coming home even though i'll come
back from you know i'm coming back from
work i'm coming back home as soon as you
know i i hit my area my you know it's
i'm still alert you know i mean i still
got to be on my toes i still got to
watch out for [ __ ]
for any little thing you know what i
mean only
you know i mean you can catch me
slipping yeah it's just probably not
[ __ ] i still gotta be on my toes and
that's because why because where you
still stay at you know what i mean
you know what i mean you where you still
live at you know and [ __ ] you're still
[ __ ] for you being who you are you're
still in that hood damn fool your
[ __ ] trophy right here get this
you know what i mean this fool you know
but
no [ __ ] i guess
a lot of trophies when you're a kid i
guess that's when we're forever there
you know what you're saying [ __ ]
what we're trying to tell you to move
for the past four years
yeah i know for sure have you
shut the [ __ ] i mean you
block you always love riding your bike
there
remember that's what you first learned
yeah i do remember wouldn't be upset as
he moved yeah so yeah [ __ ] i do remember
that it's crazy um why would you want me
out of there you should move so last
part of the question
you can make like 100 racks a month you
don't do nothing no part of the business
whatever the money is i'm just saying
that's a lot of money in your month
that's great
you're gonna do nothing all the kids are
moved out you live in a different
neighborhood away from dumb people
what are you doing
for real not just say playing more games
i'll tell you this right now what are
you gonna do what am i doing is i'm
gonna [ __ ] get my house
out of this [ __ ] country you're gonna
move away don't believe you keep going
bro you're gonna have to go visit me i'm
not visiting [ __ ] you can come over here
you skype
i'll tell you that me are
you're doing [ __ ]
you come visit me [ __ ] i'm gonna be
busy until i'm [ __ ] 90. no you're
[ __ ] not i've never retired
ever in life you're gonna be good no
i'll be fine so you're gonna be so good
where you're gonna you're gonna have to
visit me because you have nothing to
[ __ ] do
you have so much fun i just said to him
and now but it only works to me well
i'll throw up on you i don't know [ __ ] i
like i i [ __ ] i like switzerland
i like [ __ ] um
i like this segway
[ __ ] man
switzerland [ __ ] [ __ ]
what else you gotta say he said what are
you gonna do all day now where are you
what am i gonna do
it seems like you're waiting for a
specific answer i wanted something like
you know i'm just gonna you know raise
[ __ ] horses
yeah he's gonna i don't know i was
thinking like do you have something you
want to do if you had no worries no
financial problems what would you do
what would you want to build a car
like what would you do like you're gonna
go race cars all day you're gonna go
build a track like what the [ __ ] do you
gonna do besides video games that's what
i'm asking you like if you if you could
do it right now like me what would i do
i don't know i'd [ __ ] have a really
cool pool
super sick
i mean [ __ ] my [ __ ] maybe you have a
house out in the beach [ __ ] i don't know
[ __ ]
well i mean i have so many [ __ ]
visions i mean [ __ ] i could you could
tell me you want to put me up there in
the [ __ ]
middle of nowhere and i'm good tell me
what bodybuilding or something yeah it's
like yo i'm just gonna work on my upper
my upper back target practice in the
backyard first of all [ __ ] if anything i
mean look it
put this way if you're sad you and you
other than that you have nothing else to
do what am i going to do i'm going to
[ __ ] take care of me you know in my
house
you know that's going to be my health
what's more important is your health and
right now [ __ ] we can't even do that you
know i mean like we work so much that
way we don't even [ __ ] yeah this
hurts this hat you know your body
something hurts and you know what you
ain't got to even [ __ ] time to
[ __ ] even complain about it bro where
the [ __ ] you're going to complain about
it
so i mean so
[ __ ] it you we [ __ ] heating we take
it bro
but i figured that once you're in a set
area where you you're good uh-huh you
mean [ __ ] my my first thing would be
take care of yourself perfect take care
of your [ __ ] family and put them in
the best health you could put them in
you know i know for sure damn well that
right now they're not in the best house
because we're all trying to survive so
what are we doing we're all [ __ ]
eating cheap bro you know what i mean
yeah and that's you know that's [ __ ]
bad bro i mean
so me being good and all i mean [ __ ]
first thing is [ __ ] i would say
health
for sure
before anything
help finger guns away
[ __ ] out of here
that's a good answer i was waiting for
an answer that was a perfect answer i
was waiting for anything besides
oh man let's move to the beach i just
said what are you gonna do that's great
that you're probably gonna be working
out taking vitamins going to a doctor
chilling going to the beach drinking
wine
i mean i think everybody wants that bro
i think every heart [ __ ]
[ __ ] out there right now that's
working hard out there i mean [ __ ] would
want [ __ ] to [ __ ] put more into
their health and more time but [ __ ] it
you know what [ __ ] so life is so
[ __ ] fast that you know and they're
thinking more about their kids and their
[ __ ] ladies that they ain't [ __ ]
thinking about themselves you know a
real [ __ ] man yeah for sure that's
what he's [ __ ] thinking you know what
i mean all day you know what i mean [ __ ]
because i know that's where i'm [ __ ]
at you know i mean yeah that's why the
[ __ ] that's what i mean
my [ __ ] face yeah
you know
[Music]
let's go that was that was start popping
and locking i started
start popping the lock and [ __ ] yeah
come on start doing it you're good at it
come on this is dog face the dog face
interview
man is that dude still out there i don't
know
dog face yeah i think so i don't know he
just changed his outfit and does the
other channel
um so basically you're saying
take care of your health great super
awesome that's what everybody should do
when they get money
love it
great
good answer this guy
[ __ ] uh i was talking to you you know
what's the best part ever is you're
you're blocking justin boyd i can't see
his [ __ ] face so he hasn't [ __ ]
with me once
because usually he's trying to [ __ ] with
me and i haven't seen his face one time
see there's that big beard
all right that was good man yeah it's
the zigzag man on the box but he hasn't
said a word all [ __ ] day but the
whole time is he just rolling joints
right there what's the [ __ ] i hope now
it's all the weed i got left it's like a
[ __ ] i could have sworn it looked
like he's been rolling joints
that's just what i've been seeing inside
of my view
swear
people
yo um hey good job man this is the third
time third time's the charm you did a
lot better this time
oh
he can't hear it but there's applause
going
[Laughter]
but if you really want to hear you can
put your ear right here on this
no for real if you put your ear on here
you could probably hear the soundboard
you should try it no no for sure has
mister you should try it
all right that was a good episode man
thank you so much for being here thank
you for hanging out so much
good job young boy
just so good it is [ __ ] good compared
to the first episode where you were
really having to drag them through them
oh yeah remember i had to hold you by
the ear i'm like come on tell me about
drug stuff that was fun i was sick
i mean buzz
me out of nowhere
out of nowhere bro [ __ ] not even 12
hours tomorrow
we talked about this last year no no no
no no not this last week we're talking
about the first ones yeah don't hit me
the first one
you wanted you want to be on the podcast
no [ __ ] guys
on tuesdays not tomorrow hey can i have
a couple more days my [ __ ] ass it
wasn't tomorrow you wanna be on a
podcast it was like tomorrow bro
um you know i wanted to be on the
podcast a question i want you to be in
the podcast when you do it
oh bro and i was like it's okay if you
don't want to you're scared [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of here
i was editing footage and i heard that
in the background of the clip all right
i'm gonna i'm gonna tell marty you're
scared
oh yeah oh for when i called him last
week
yeah that was funny yeah
did you tell martin you're super scared
i wasn't you know i wasn't even prepared
for today bro i was [ __ ] already
you came on time you're like you got
here on time you put the notes no i'm
tired i have nothing being on here being
being somewhere on time saying you're
never on time and you were on time at
least today thomas knew you were going
to be and i did i did say i did say he's
going to be on time i had
faith in you because the last time i
called you and you said i'm here and go
what you're here on time you go it's the
new me
there you go
that's why i said no he'll be on time
today because i think he's going to
start being on time today
and it's going to happen good job
if you had the headphones on you would
hear the applause
oh really
put your [ __ ] ear to this and you'll
hear it do it marty
thank you so much i appreciate it um so
yeah for everyone that watched number
one you
you did a great job you stuttered your
ass away through that one that was great
you hated it
can we and marty left in the whole chunk
of you said hey bring ding all back i'm
gonna just cut that out and that's what
freaking freaked him out that's what
made him like he didn't even cut it out
what the [ __ ]
i asked him to cut he's forgot it wasn't
intentionally a jerk for months he was
like fool you you left it in there i'm
like i wasn't and i asked him did i just
forgot
what if he forgot
i didn't edit it oh this guy
i said we forgot
he didn't even listen to the words yeah
actually you gotta understand uh a
three-second book
[ __ ] haystack we don't yeah that's
true it's true
but
number two you came back and it was
super awesome it was way fun you were
way more [ __ ] up
you you talked but i had to say i wasn't
that [ __ ] up i had to drag you through
that one and then everybody thought i
was being mean to you and it was really
funny everything comes i was being mean
to you
like don't be trying to worry you little
[ __ ] jerk
what do you mean
brody
yeah
you get to
just go okay i want to hear it it's been
him since he's been little i mean
i don't know what it is but you know i
think it was ever since you know
this is why i left him
okay you know
it was hard for him eat the sand
eat this
big and strong
so anyways
ever since then you know he's always
been really aggressive you know i mean
i give him his way not aggressive you
know what i mean it's like today i
wasn't going to be here but he told me
that if you're not here i'm never going
to talk to you again
oh [ __ ] bro let's go i got to be there
let's go
file all this back through child support
and show yes
dude
that's not golden
that's not golden
right yep
so um
thank you that was a good one it's my
pinky ring i'm just trying to be like
you
so i'm just sitting here chilling um
that was good you barely smoked
my ass
now it's getting full
i'm kidding
it's a joke man that was fun for
everyone still here thank you thank you
for being here for everyone back there
besides justin thank you guys so much
for sticking through it it was fun
justin's really short no beard
no beard no bars justin's like i don't
know why the [ __ ] oh geez [ __ ] here
what the [ __ ]
why would you think that
hey
you know that percentage of the
percentage of the fans that are
listening to they're like who the [ __ ]
is oh gee [ __ ] hojie who the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ] guy you know i mean what
she's third time here yeah i don't think
are you talking about the third time
here
i'm just saying justin
[Music]
[Laughter]
i don't know if we can put it on here
we'll just use this bts clip you're
gonna hit it um thanks for being here
thank you for telling us all these crazy
stories that last 30 minutes unreal
unnecessary i was just
that's [ __ ] insane i had one question
see what i would have pissed my pants
if i went away i would have [ __ ] myself
so because how bad i had to piss that he
wrapped it all up with a really nice
inspirational like health
moment i love that
and then we just kept going
what happened
[Laughter]
um did you hear it
no okay thank you so much uh that was
fun i don't know how long this episode's
been got here you just got here
yeah i did
mr rooney
i'm just [ __ ] with you i know you are
sorry i'm trying to end this podcast i'm
trying to like think of a way to for him
to stop just he's just ranting at this
are you still an acid
you're still on that he's all sideways
and shoot when you look at him he is
sideways the whole time you should make
him sideways when he watches him
you should do it you sure you're going
to watch this episode yeah are you sure
you're going to watch this episode watch
it
that was not real that was a sure on
enthusiasm
last night he didn't check his [ __ ]
dms
you don't even post what the [ __ ] you're
a jerk
i check all my [ __ ] dms here's the
edge room i mean if you're in the
backboard
i mean dude i apologize i [ __ ] i get
flooded you know in the back i do like
people that you know in the back you'll
be like
[ __ ] like right now i think i'm like
at 980 something damn requests yes bro
like messages from you know i try to go
to most of them and try bringing much
people i can't bring them in
but you know i mean [ __ ] i didn't want
to ask you your instagram you don't ever
use it every last episode i said go to
og's instagram and tell him please post
he's posted twice since then
it sure didn't work didn't work
no [ __ ] [ __ ] it's [ __ ] it's hard i
mean [ __ ]
look at put it this way basically
right now i'm doing the same [ __ ] every
day so the only thing i don't want to
board you guys with the same [ __ ] every
day so don't post nothing well there you
see that's why there you go
stop it i don't you have access to the
biggest display in the basement in the
state i could i guess you know [ __ ]
and people want to see just [ __ ]
weeding [ __ ] you know regular [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] i could do they do they
do want to see you having fun
you should start live streaming like you
facetime me
this will have a show in eight [ __ ]
seconds but yeah let's get this is that
dog face brother we need to get them
together and that's what's gonna happen
og and dog face okay so this guy he's
doing dog face it's never going to end
you guys have too much alike
[ __ ] we got to bring that guy in here
let's see
he's actually been here the whole time
oh really he's right behind you
it's funny he's
that he's gonna pop up as a filler
watch
marty what else do you want to say to
this guy i'm just i was trying to end it
i just got so [ __ ] thrown off and
then here we go
all over the place [ __ ] know
everywhere
this whole last 30 minutes has been so
like i said ridiculous marty do you have
anything else you want to say this
full-grown man
this is [ __ ] good
i don't remember half the [ __ ]
episode i don't know at all i remember
i remember when you guys were both
literally just always trying to team up
on me both of you guys yeah i remember
that
i remember we used to noogie him
and before he had his mustache it was
crazy
let's say [ __ ] marty
all right he remembers that nookie's man
yeah he does he does he remembers the
nook he's in the five secs
all right let's end this let's be done i
think it's been a while
and we should end it thank you marty
anything else
thank you as always man the [ __ ]
legend graces us here yeah he's talking
about me thank you
i'm sorry
i just [ __ ] marty's whole thing up
he's talking about you all right
being real cool
me being real cool
it's [ __ ] bad
you know what you actually paid
attention and i said nothing that made
no sense this time no no no
before before we do end this [ __ ] about
[ __ ] anything about being cool
i literally [ __ ] wanna let [ __ ]
everybody out there no [ __ ]
any [ __ ] issues with [ __ ] pills
there's nothing [ __ ] cool about what
i said about my story that i tell of
what how much i've took
you know don't [ __ ] take that you
know and try to [ __ ]
do what i did you know what i mean
because that's not [ __ ] cool there's
nothing [ __ ] cool about it
because [ __ ] i wouldn't want anybody to
[ __ ] think that that was cool that
you know more [ __ ] talking about
[ __ ] pills and [ __ ] no one thought it
was cool when i was taking it you know
just
you got your point across pretty well
you almost died
all right yeah don't worry don't don't
think that this is that that's that was
a good thing nobody went like no for
sure i just want to put that set that
out there because i'm pretty sure
[ __ ] there's somebody out there might
be watching that might have that problem
i might think [ __ ] it this dude did this
much maybe i could take that much uh
okay i get what you're saying
don't be a [ __ ] stop taking pills you
know [ __ ] that yeah you know what i mean
does your name play [ __ ] that [ __ ]
before we leave
last thing
did you know that the dare program
listen care about drugs yes they were
outside of my apartment and they were
outside of best buy the other day and we
talked to them
you know they don't care about drugs
anymore
the dare program is only about suicide
prevention and mental health now oh
because she was like do you guys want to
share it go
film a weed video i was vlogging like i
was probably the bad people for this she
goes oh we i smoke he's fine this is
like dare i go i know
so you know it's for mental health now
[ __ ] say more and then i heard her out
it's all about mental health so we don't
have a dare anymore this is what i'm
trying to say so here's the dare
he just told you don't glorify any of
that [ __ ] don't think it was cool all of
it was bad [ __ ] that took away like
[ __ ] 18 years god damn of your life
you were on that [ __ ] nothing
glorified about that all bad
right for sure besides that anything
else you want to say
i think we're straight my boy all right
so he wanted to say man thomas you're so
super cool
i look up to you i dress like you how do
i jump like you
and i will show you all the calf
exercises i do to dunk
all right right after this [ __ ] guy
thank you guys so much for being here i
appreciate you so much
you don't think you're gonna get dunked
on right now there's a basketball court
out there now
boy you can't dunk on me marty tell him
i can dunk on a regulation-sized rim
[ __ ] guy lie for me
[Laughter]
[ __ ] i see that shell like really
full like [ __ ]
i bought it for my little brother he's
eight and my other brother bought him
the same court and he opened his present
first and i went oh i guess i'll just
[ __ ] take it back to amazon i didn't
want to ship it so i just kept the [ __ ]
that's why it's a child's court it's not
it's not big enough anyway i'll show you
the calf exercises thank you so much for
being here we've been trying to end this
[ __ ] for a long time appreciate it um
you did great you did good you talked a
lot better you should watch this episode
this time
ah he just said he would and now he's
saying he's not
jerk
he might it was good
i mean i really don't i really don't
care you should watch it i think i think
i no i don't have to watch it because
it's already already because i lived it
man yeah i knew you're going to say that
that's already programmed in my head
you don't even remember what we talked
about tell me two topics for sure tell
me two topics if you remember at all i
mean come on but we're gonna talk about
the mexico you said mexico antacid
um
two more
yeah we talked about
[ __ ] the gambling
yeah gotta hear something
you know
little [ __ ] ever since he's been a kid
he's never stopped all the [ __ ]
questions
20 questions questions 20 questions
remember
that's what twenty one
twenty one twenty one what happens after
this right you put cigarette burns
cigars in my arm for spilling paint in
the crash
is that what you're gonna do
all right that was a that was a
breakfast club reference we'll get that
on out of here with a breakfast club
reference thank you guys so much for
being here i appreciate you for marty
o'neil drastic graphics from me from
no g because where's the packs at uh i
know there's no packs anymore thank you
so much for being here and thank you for
not crying you didn't tear up once i
appreciate you thank you for being here
have a dope ass day
every time i ask you you want anything
else to say i say something stupid after
because you're done talking and it's
funny to me that the last thing i said
was i'm stupid
[ __ ] jerk you did good
you did good don't worry
[Music]
perfect perfect
[Music]